[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir. Nous vous recevrons
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
Syerview. Nous sommes en direct.
On a décidé de vous recevoir pour parler
d'énergie, de croissance, de pollution
et de solution. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? On va
commencer par Nicolas Mayant.
Bonsoir. Donc Nicolas Mayant, je suis
ingénieur conseil énergie et de
transport. Je fais partie de l'ASPO,
l'association pour l'étude du pic
pétrolier et gazier et aussi membre des
éconoclastes et conseiller scientifique
au sein de France Stratégie.
Jean Laerr. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Oui. Donc je suis un
géologue géophysicien à la retraite
depuis pas mal de temps. Euh donc je me
suis intéressé au pétrole parce que
j'étais passionné de pêche sous-marine.
Donc c'était le début de
l'exploration pétrolier Rchor et j'ai
exploré tous les grands déserts du
monde. Alors, j'ai commencé par le Sara
où j'ai participé à la découverte des du
champ d'assimé Saoud qui est le plus
grand champ de pétrole d'Afrique et le
deimal qui est le plus grand champ de
gaz d'Afrique et qui à l'heure actuelle
alimente encore pour par production la
moitié du budget algérien. Donc vous
voyez, on a laissé des choses en
Algérie. Après avoir exploré pendant 5
ans les déserts saariens, je suis allé
explorer les déserts australiens. Donc
où là on n' pas fait de découverte mais
alors que le Sara était était un un
désert très fréquenté où on trouvait des
restes
de l'homme notamment des fléchettes de
des fléchettes des restes de
parce qu'il y a assimil la similance
était fertile
euh l'Australie le Simpson désert moi
j'étais dans des endroits où il y avait
jamais eu d' d'êtres humains qui avaient
pénétré on a on a tracé C'est on était
les premiers à traverser Simpson Desert
avec un camion alors que ça race ça a
été fait par expédition Citroën dans les
années 30 ou plus je parle pas et donc
après ça après 5 ans d'Australie les à
ce moment-là je suis parti au Canada
j'ai là j'ai fait les grands déserts
gelés du hein du grand nord du grand
nord canadien et en même temps aussi un
peu du côté américain
et puis après donc 15 ans d'expatriation
je suis retourné au siège
en 72
de chez Total.
Chez Total puisque j'étais tout j'ai
commencé avec la CFP qui est devenue
Total. Et là donc j'ai j'ai
je me suis occupé de négociation dans
les années 72. Je crois que je suis allé
11 fois en Amérique du Sud. J'ai signé
des contrats un peu en Pérou, en
Bolivie.
Euh après euh donc je me suis occupé de
l'étude des bassins. Après j'étais le
directeur des études techniques
et euh en 91
président qui s'appelait Tchurou et qui
a décidé que euh à ce moment-là
les actionnaires demandaient de faire
des taux de profit de l'ordre de 15 %.
Donc il disait un varil à 15 %
d'actualisation à 10h en valeur nulle.
Donc je ne fais plus d'études de futur.
Donc tout ce qui les études futur, je
veux plus en entend parler. Moi j'étais
en charge de
des études donc de de de prévision et
cetera. Et donc j'ai été mis à la
retraite à 61 60 ans à 60 ans alors que
moi je voulais rester jusqu'à 65.
Et donc comme j'avais
beaucoup travaillé sur les données
de pétrolière qui sont des données
confidentielles qu'on achète avec
compagnie de d'espionnage hein comme
pétroconsultant.
Je suis allé voir les gens de
pétroconsultant qui qui étaient
simplement des collecteurs de données
hein qui maintenant qui a été racheté
par une boîte américaine qui s'appelle
HS qui qui qui contrôle toutes les
données pétrolières mécanique
tout des armes ils ont acheté Jens et
cetera et je leur ai dit à
pétroconsultant
euh vous avez les données. Moi j'ai une
méthode de
pour les exploiter et faire des
prévisions. Donc je vous êtes d'accord.
Donc pendant plusieurs années, j'ai fait
des rapports avec les meilleurs experts
français, notamment AI Perodon qui était
le qui a été qui qui est le meilleur
géologue pétrolier qui a écrit des tas
de bouquins sur sur l'exploration
pétrolière et notamment il a été le
premier à dire parce que si vous voulez
autrefois le pétrole était exploité
comme on a commencé à exploiter le
pétrole en France à Péchelbronne parce
qu'il y avait des suintement
et on exploitait les le le pét pétrole
comme médicament et puis pour graisser
les roues des brouettes. Donc Michel
Brand ça a démarré, ça a été la première
compagnie action euh pétrolière, ça a
été en France Pel Bron. En plus de ça,
est-ce que ça vous parle les sep sœurs ?
Ah ben je vais vous parler des sep sœurs
bien sûr.
Alors je avant avant je vais vous
couper, je suis désolé. Je vais redonner
la parole à Nicolas Mayant.
Ah oui, je suis trop toujours trop long.
C'est toujours un plaisir, ne vous
inquiétez pas, on a le temps et on va
pouvoir prendre tout notre temps.
Nicolas Mayant, vous nous avez parlé de
du pic gazier, du pic du pic pétrolier.
Euh est-ce que à votre avis les
politiques sont informés, correctement
informé de ce phénomène ? Alors, je
pense que les politiques en ont entendu
parler, mais quand vous parlez de
contrainte sur la disponibilité de
pétrole, ce qu'on va vous dire, la
première chose, c'est il y a 40 ans, on
nous disait qu'il restait 40 ans de
pétrole et 40 ans plus tard, il reste
toujours 40 ans de pétrole. Donc, a
priori, dans 40 ans, il en restera
toujours 40 ans.
Mais à quel prix ?
Mais à quel prix ? Mais surtout, en
fait, ils ont pas la bonne information.
Euh c'est-à-dire que vous avez
différents types de réserves, les
réserves prouvées euh qu'on appelle
réserves 1P qui sont des réserves
financières et politique. Et puis
ensuite les réserves qu'on appelle de P
prouvé plus euh possible qui elles sont
euh les réserves techniques qui sont les
données confidentielles dont par les
gens. Si on s'intéresse aux réserves
impé où vous avez des pays, je prends
souvent l'exemple du Venezuela. Euh le
Venezuela en 2010, Hugo Chavez a décidé
qui voulait avoir les plus grandes
réserves de pétrole au monde. Et donc il
est devenu du jour au lendemain le plus
grand pays. Euh c'était les réserves
financières, sauf qu'aujourd'hui le
Venezuela concrètement allit peut-être
10e réserve mondiale. Et donc ça ce sont
les données qui sont utilisées par les
par les politiques et qui sont
communiquées au grand public. Les
données techniques et confidentielles,
elles vous disent que il y a 60 ans, il
restait 30 ans de pét il y a 30 ans, il
resté 60 ans de pétrole et
qu'aujourd'hui il en reste 30 ans. Donc
concrètement euh on s on s'achemine
petit à petit vers une contrainte sur la
disponibilité de pétrole. J'en pourra en
parler. On parle de on parle de plateau
ondulant euh et qui est qu'on a une
difficulté à aller augmenter et mettre
en production des nouveaux champ de
pétrole.
Jean le bumpy plateau, le le plateau
ondulé. Alors, si vous voulez, moi je
vais vous raconter donc l'histoire donc
du pic pétrolier puisque donc je vous ai
dit que j'ai commencé à écrire des
rapports pouroconsultante. Là, c'est là
où j'ai connu euh qui travaillait un
autre géologue qui était à la retraite,
Coline Campbell, qui était un géologue
anglais qui a beaucoup sévi en Amérique
du Sud, en Amérique du Nord et en
Norvège. Et donc on a écrit des des
rapports,
c'était des rapports très techniques qui
faisaient le dernier. Si vous voulez, il
y avait trois volumes, c'était ça.
C'était c'était par kilo, hein.
Qui c'est qui lisait ces rapports ?
Ben, c'était pétre consultant qui les il
nous donnait les données, on les
exploitait, on faisait tous les
graphiques, il les imprimait et il les
vendait. Et on était payé en royalty.
Donc on était pas du tout, on
travaillait pas pour eux. ont travaillé
sur leur données et on était payé donc
comme un écrivain en royalty sur les
ventes sur les ventes mais les ventes
c'était des ventes qui se le rapport par
exemple avec Cble c'était 10000 dollars
l'unité hein donc c'était pas des des
rapports à 100 à 100 € hein bon mais qui
était acheté par les principaux
pétroliers qui voulaient en savoir plus
il paraît que la CIA la CIA l'a aussi
acheté mais là moi j'ai jamais dans la
liste des royalties j'ai jamais vu c'est
hier mais bon et donc
quand on était avec Pétroconsultant
avant qu' soit racheté par IHS qui une
boîte américaine on a été interviewé
par scientifique américaine et donc
scientifique américaine nous a nous a
proposé d'écrire un article qui
s'appelait The End of Chiple donc en
mars 98
au moment où le baril était à 13 dollars
Ça a été traduit, cet article a été
traduit en français pour la le magazine
pour les sciences, la fin du pétrole, la
fin du pétrole bon marché. Et enfin en
fin donc 98, le pétrole est tombé à 10
dollars du baril. Donc on on dit
qu'est-ce que c'est chez Charlot qui
parle de la fin du pétrole bon marché.
Donc pendant
10 ans, on a été considéré comme les un
peu les Charlot. Et puis ce qu'il y a
c'est que en 2007, donc on y a après ça,
après écrire cet article Coline Campbell
avec d'ailleurs
le professeur nucléaire
suédois qui voulait savoir quand est-ce
que les Suédois se remettraient à à
accepter le le nucléaire. Donc à
proposer la logistique parce que quand
on est des géologues et qu'on veut faire
passer la parole, il faut de la
logistique. Il faut bon un moment on
avait pétroconsultant. Donc il a il a
offert
l'école de à UPSALA donc en Suède et de
faire d'aspo des des aspos
internationaux. Donc on a fait des état
de conférences internationale tous les
ans à Paris à à Berlin.
Et le dernier le dernier en dote en000
2007 ça a été à Coke puisque de Colin
c'était qui était en France éétait
retiré en Irlande et là le secrétaire
d'état l'ancien secrétaire d'état de
l'énergie Chessiger nous est venu faire
le vous savez le
gas speaker en disant vous avez gagné
donc en 2007 le pétrole le le le pic
pétrolier était accepté par les
politiques parce que tout le monde On
voyit qu'on ne faisait plus de
découverte puisque le le mais 2008 est
arrivé le le le pétrole de chist hein
et la crise et la crise mais c'est pas
la crise non c'est c'est surtout le
pétrole de chiste qui fait qui qui s'est
envolé euh parce que
à ce moment-là il y avait deux choses.
D'abord, le prix de du pétrole était
monté en 2008 à 140 dollars du baril.
Vous savez pourquoi ? C était les
Chinois qui faisaient le plein de stock
pour les Jeux Olympiques, hein. Donc il
ils ont racheté jusqu'au mois de juillet
et puis après ils ont donc il a il a
dégringoulé
mais il était quand même fort élevé
et donc
le pétrole étant le prix du pétrole
était assez élevé, on pouvait exploiter
du du pétrole qui est pas du tout dans
les chistes mais dans des gris compacts
grâce à la fracturation et au forage
horizontaux.
Ces deux techniques sont des techniques
qui sont utilisées depuis 50 ans. Euh
par exemple euh
le premier gisement de gaz au aux
États-Unis, c'était le gaz de de schist
de Fredonia en 1821. Mais à ce
moment-là, si vous voulez, le gaz était
pour l'éclairage et l'éclairage était
fait par soit du gaz, soit du gaz de
l'huile de baleine. Et l'huile de
baleine à ce temps-là, c'était 1000
dollars du baril.
Et si vous voulez euh quand est arrivé
la découverte
en 1859 de Drake en Pennsylvanie
où ils ont forêt trouvé du pétrole dans
un endroit qui s'appelait H Cric donc
qui avait des des indices ils ont trouvé
donc du pétrole à 25 à 21 m de
profondeur. Vous voyez, c'était pas
profond, mais ça a été du pétrole euh
donc qui a jailli en quantité et qui a
fait écrouler le prix du baril qui fait
que ça a sauvé les bennes et ça a tué le
le gaz de chiste de Fronia, donc si vous
voulez qui était déjà du gaz de chiste,
ça a été abandonné et ça et il n'est
revenu que plus tard. On on faisait la
fracturation en ce temps-là, on faisait
pas on la fracturation se faisait à coud
de euh de nitroglycérine, on mettait des
explosifs
et puis on fracturait et cetera. Mais
dans les années 2000 2008, on a commencé
des des promoteurs ont commencé à
exploiter le gaz de chiste du du Barnet
et ça ils ont fait ils ont fait ma
question concernait les politiques et
leur capacité à s'informer correctement
de la réalité de de ce bumpy plateau de
de ce pic énergétique.
Est-ce que vous avez participé à des
réunions de cabinet ministériel ? Est-ce
qu'on vous a on vous a sollicité durant
votre con ?
Ah non, parce que depuis depuis si vous
voulez, moi j'ai participé dans les
années euh 97, c'était il y avait encore
euh le le cach commissariat au plan.
Donc j'ai participé à des à ce
moment-là, j'étais déjà j'étais à la
retraite. Donc je me suis je me souviens
la première réunion au commissariat du
plan. Donc on s'est présenté, il était
en train de personnes puis j'étais le
dernier et puis j'ai dit à tout le monde
voyez vous êtes tous là voyez j'ai
entendu hein vous êtes payé pour être
là. Moi je suis la retraite, je suis pas
payé, je suis seul mais je suis le seul
qui est libre qui est libre de parler.
Vous ne pouvez pas dire quelque chose
qui ne plaira pas à votre patron. Moi je
peux.
Donc j'ai j'ai participé à des hein des
rapports de l'énergie en en 98 je crois
où un moment il voulait pas mettre mes
vues et j'ai dit bon ben si vous mettez
pas mes vues moi je vais les dire à la
presse. Alors ils les ont mis mais enfin
ils les ont mis un peu dans le quoi.
Quel était vos vues ? C'était quoi vos
vues
avec qui allit qui allaiit avoir un pic
pétrolier ?
Et donc pour eux ce qui signifie
Ah ben non mais pour eux pour un
politique si vous voulez toute notre
société de consommation est basée sur la
croissance. Alors la la croissance c'est
de quoi
c'est c'est de quoi la croissance quand
on dit tout le monde parle de la
croissance c'est la croissance qu'elle
est mesurée c'est le PIB. Bon et le PIB
dans les années 90 c'était c'était ça
dépendait
du capital et du travail. Tout le monde
les écomodistes disaient c'est 50 %
capital 50 % travail.
Et à ce moment-là moi j'avais commencé à
étudier. Je me souviens il y a il y a
une vingtaine d'années, mon premier
visiteur, c'était un gars qui un
australien qui venait du Xiro qui était
l'équivalent du CERNE CNRS
euh non du CNRS. Et je lui dis "Mais
pour moi quand je regarde le PIB, je
vois que la part de l'énergie c'est ça
fait 5 %, c'est négligeable mais son
effet est important."
Il me dit "Ben bien sûr, vous avez
raison. Il y a des nouveaux
économistes notamment Cumel en Allemagne
et Bobert qui est qui était à l'INADE,
un américain qui qui est qui est
économiste qui est mais qui a commencé
sa carrière
comme physicien d'ailleurs.
Et donc je leur ai envoyé un email en
disant notamment à
à Aubéret en disant de vous me
connaissez pas mais je viens d'apprendre
que le cap que le PIB dépend énormément
l'énergie me dit mais oui oui bien sûr
je confirme d'ailleurs je connais vos
écrits et oui oui je confirme. Donc
maintenant, si vous voulez, il est admis
par que le PIB dépend à 50 %
de l'énergie
malgré son faible si on regarde en en
réalité
35 % du capital et 15 % du travail. Donc
les bon mais euh
donc à l'heure actuelle tout le monde
vous promet de la croissance, donc la
croissance du PIB, mais il faudrait que
la la l'énergie continue à croître. Or
euh je prétends que le
pétrole que l'on appelle conventionnel
mais personne n'est n'est n'est n'est
d'accord. Il y a pas de consensus. Comme
je dis dans le monde du football, il y a
des règles, il y a des arbitres et il y
a des cartons rouges
et il y a Bernard Tapis.
Bon oui et dans le monde du pétrole, il
y a pas de règle, il y a pas d'arbitre
et il y a pas de carton rouge. Donc tout
le monde peut dire n'importe quoi. Et
notamment quand l'Arabie Saoudite
décrète que depuis 30 ans, ils ont 260
milliards de réserves, bien que ça
voudrait dire restante. Ça voudrait dire
que chaque année pendant 30 ans, ils ont
découvert autant qu'ils ont produit.
C'est absolument improbable. C'est pas
c'est pas par rapport aux évolutions de
techniques de récupération ici.
Non non non non non non parce que les
techniques de récupération de toute
façon en conventionnel les techniques
elles sont connues. Euh on a quand on a
découvert à Saou on a dit ça fait 10
milliards maintenant on est à 12 mais
donc on était dans on avait pris un
chiffre rond. Non, d'ailleurs les
chiffres ça été 17 et 10 et puis bon euh
non dans le conventionnel il y a pas il
y a pas question de de prix de toute
façon. Toute façon, un champ ça
s'exploite sur 50 ans. Donc c'est pas le
prix une année qui importe. C'est c'est
et puis une fois qu'on a fait les
investissements
quand ils ont compris que le PIB était
interconnecté avec la consommation
énergétique, ils ont ils ont eu un petit
peu froid. Ah ben maintenant mais
maintenant c'est que d'abord d'abord il
ne vous parle vous parle de croissance,
il vous dit pas du PIB et puis quand il
s'il vous disent du PIB mais vous savez
que vous avez quatre PIB vous avez un
PIB en valeur courante ou en valeur
constante ou à parité d'achat courant ou
constant. Donc par exemple la France, si
vous prenez le classement euh euh
l'année dernière pour la la Banque
mondiale, vous pouvez dire qu'elle est
en 5e, 6e, 7e ou 9e position. Mais ça
dépend de votre définition du PIB, mais
personne ne vous ne vous définit. Quand
quelqu'un vous dit quelque chose, il
vous définit jamais de quoi il parle.
Donc il peut dire un peu tout ce qu'il
veut puisque sa définition
je
vais je vais redonner la parole à
Nicolas May.
Non non, vous me parlez pas trop, il y a
aucun souci, hein. Euh Nicolas Mayon,
est-ce que le les politiques nous
maintiennent dans un brouillard ?
Euh euh est-ce que les les scientifiques
sont maintenus dans un brouillard ou
est-ce que on n'apporte pas assez
correctement le problème en face ?
Est-ce qu'on met pas assez les doigts
dedans ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Je pense qu'ils sont pas conscients euh
je pense qu'ils sont pas conscients du
problème énergétique. Je ne pense pas
qu'il croi à cette contrainte. Euh comme
disait gens, il y a les travaux de Gael
Giro notamment qui qui est venu chez
vous hein qui parle de dépendance je
crois presque à 60 %. C'est la
dépendance de la croissance du PIB. Donc
pour augmenter le PIB 21, il faut
augmenter l'énergie de 0,6 en gros. Donc
ça c'est des choses qui sont admis par
des experts. Aujourd'hui, on ne se rend
pas compte et on ne comprend pas
effectivement que si on a des
difficultés aussi à croître notre PIB,
c'est parce qu'on va avoir des
difficultés à à faire croître la
consommation d'énergie. Alors, ce qui
est vrai, c'est que on consomme de moins
en moins d'énergie pour générer un
dollar de PIB, mais ça ne ça ne diminue
en rien notre dépendance. C'est juste
qu'on en consomme un peu moins, mais la
dépendance reste extrêmement forte. Donc
quand quand on va quand on ne va plus
réussir, parce que le pétrole, il faut
bien le dire, c'est le sang de
l'économie. C'est le pétrole, c'est ça
qui permet d'avoir cette économie
mondialisée qui permet d'avoir des
bateaux qui transportent toutes les
marchandises autour de nous qui nous
permet de nous déplacer tous les jours.
Le jour où on a une contrainte de
pétrole, les choses se compliquent très
vite. Il suffit de voir en France quand
vous avez quelques quelques stockages
pétroliers qui sont bloqués en 3 jours à
Paris, il y a plus d'essence. Vous avez
un problème quand il y a plus d'essens
apparu en 3 jours, c'est que les gens
peuvent plus aller travailler. Et donc
là, je crois qu'aujourd'hui cette
contrainte là,
il l'anticipe pas en tout cas disons à
court moyen terme.
Jean vous les rebondir.
Oui. Vous vous parlez vous parlez de
ce que les gens ne sont pas enfin je
dirais que l'information
l'information est très manipulée et elle
est surtout réservée.
Euh je vais vous citer un exemple. Un
exemple, tout le monde, notamment les
gilets jaunes, réclament l'égalité
fiscale. Bon, donc moi, je dis d'égalité
fiscale. Très bien. Est-ce que vous
savez, est-ce que vous avez jamais
entendu dire que le gasol que vous
consommez, hein, le gasol hein est très
performant et on vous dit un moteur
diesel consomme 20 % de moins qu'un
moteur d'essence. Alors tout le monde
vous dit c'est parce que le moteur
diesel est conçu, il y a pas de bougie,
la compression et cetera. Bon c'est vrai
en partie mais la grande réalité c'est
que 1 L d'essence
hein est 13 % moins énergétique qu'un
lre de gasoil. Est-ce que vous avez
jamais entendu ça ? Alors moi j'ai
commencé à faire des recherches et j'ai
dit 7 % et puis Nicolas m'a corrigé. Il
m'a dit "Mais non c'est pas 7 % c'est
12. En définitif, c'est 13. Enfin, ça
dépend des chiffres. Donc 1 L
vous vous quand vous achetez
de de l'essence ou du diesel, vous
achetez de l'énergie. Donc c'est normal
que vous payez hein, puisque c'est vendu
au litre et non pas au poids. Si c'était
vendu au poids, il y aurait pas de
problème puisque il est 13 % plus lourd.
C'est ça pour ça qu'il est plus
énergétique. Et donc à l'heure actuelle,
l'égalité fiscale, c'est pas comme le
dit le gouvernement, il faut vendre le
le fioule au même prix que l'essence, il
faut le vendre 13 %. Donc moi, j'estime
la plus chère que l'essence au litre.
Donc cette niche fiscale, vous savez
combien ça représentait
hein ? En 2017, c'était 16 milliards
d'euros. Alors l'ISF à côté avec 4
milliards, il a l'air ridicule. Si vous
faites le cumul depuis 1980
de cette fiche f niche fiscale, c'est
500 milliards d'euros.
C'est c'est colossal. Mais vous en avez
jamais entendu parler de ça ? De la
niche fiscale du gazol ? Non. Que que le
gazol est 13 % plus énergétique ? Non.
Nicolas Mayant si la l'approvisionnement
au pétrole se se tend
vous modélisez comment les tensions sur
la société sur les marchés financiers
sur le local ?
Alors déjà que si on a moins de pétrole
pour faire de la croissance, on va quand
même avoir un petit problème pour
commencer à rembourser nos dettes.
Donc on va quand même vers une
instabilité forte du système financier.
Donc on a toujours les les banquiers
centraux pompiers pyoman qui sont là.
peut-être pour éteindre le feu ou alors
peut-être pour l'aggraver. Mais plus
concrètement parlant, quand il y a un
souci sur le pétrole, alors c'est pas
exact c'est pas que la la raison des
gilets jaunes, mais il faut quand même
se rappeler ce qui s'est passé sur les
gilets jaunes, ce qui a créé ce qui a ce
qui a allumé la mèche, c'est que vous
avez des gens qui devaient faire un
compromis, un choix entre faire le plein
de course et faire le plein d'essence.
Donc ils av c'était pas une contrainte
de disponibilité mais ça l'était par le
prix. Euh et donc et certaines personnes
disent "Ben moi, ça me coûte plus cher
d'aller travailler avec le prix que ça
me coûte que de rester chez moi." Quand
vous avez demain une contrainte sur le
pétrole, si on est moins improvisionné,
on a directement, je dis c'est le sang
de la société, donc le cœur de la
société s'arrête de battre. Donc il faut
anticiper ça et il faut trouver des
solutions pour que les gens qui en
dépendent le plus et c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde. Les gens qui habitent en
ville par exemple ne dépendent pas de
pétrole. Mais il y a beaucoup de gens en
France qui n'ont pas le choix. Et ces
gens-là, il faut qu'on puisse les aider
à s'organiser pour qu'ils trouvent des
solutions pour moins dépendre.
Jean, euh durant votre longue carrière,
euh vous avez connu la guerre, vous avez
connu
les restrictions ? Oui.
Les restrictions, vous avez connu le
premier choc pétrolier.
Oui.
Vous avez connu
Oui, mais j'ai connu les 30 glorieuses.
C'était bien ça, non ? depuis 47 le 45
he à à 73 hein parce qu'en définitive
comme je dis le meilleur le plus grand
cadeau que m'a fait mon père qui a fait
les deux guerres c'est quand j'ai
commencé ma carrière l'Europe était à
reconstruire donc si vous voulez et plus
les pays ont été
anéantis hein c'est-à-dire les plus qui
ont eu le plus de de de croissance
c'est-à-dire l'Allemagne et le Japon
enfin la France donc on a reconstruit et
les tr glorieuses donc je les ai connu
Mais mais je me suis pas aperçu que
c'était des tres glorieuses.
Tout tout et et c'était la croissance du
pétrole, c'était 7 % par an. C'est
prodigieux. Alors que maintenant on est
pratiquement plat. Si vous prenez le
conventionnel, on est on est plutôt plat
et puis on va on va décroître. Donc si
vous voulez euh
vous ne réalisez pas quand quand tout
quand tout va bien. Vous ne vous le
réalisez que que quand ça va commencer à
aller mal. et et moi je dis je suis
désolé mais je vais laisser à mes petits
enfants euh une société de consommation
qu'il faut complètement changer. Et donc
je leur dis euh vous allez il faut que
vous changiez. C'est pas c'est pas moi à
changer, c'est vous qui allez changer
mais vous allez devoir changer parce que
la société de consommation qui est basée
sur l'énergie et la dépense, la société
de consommation, il faut se jeter pour
il faut jeter consommer tous vos hein
vos vos instruments, ils sont conçus au
bout de 2 ans, il faut les changer hein.
Bah ça, il faudra que ça change.
Votre génération, est-ce qu'elle est-ce
qu'elle a compris ce qu'elle a ce
qu'elle avait achevé pendant cette rue
glorieuse ? Est-ce qu'elle a compris le
le le problème qu'elle laisse aux
nouvelle génération ?
Oui. Oui. Parce que parce que si vous
voulez, moi je me suis beaucoup
intéressé par aux vraies données et
cetera, mais mais je je suis effrayé de
voir comment euh la la plupart des
information Je suis désolé,
l'information
en France est mauvaise. Vous voulez moi
je je
voulais simplement avoir quand j'ai fait
les l'études par exemple, j'ai fait un
papier sur les gilets jaunes hein qui
était le nombre de de foyers fiscaux.
Bon l'INC qui est payé comme je dis moi
j'ai payé tout ça c'est moi qui paye en
contribuable.
les droits de l'homme de 1789 nous dit
qu'on a le droit à l'information.
Bon mais non l'inc de fait des études
qui sont que locales qui de temps en
temps une année il vous donne le nom de
foyers fiscaux de l'autre vous l'avez
pas. J'ai été incapable de retrouver le
nombre de foyers fiscaux en France dans
un rapport vous allez dans des pays
comme
la Grande-Bretagne où là il y a le free
information Act. Eux, ils vous donnent
des séries euh historiques
complètes. Moi, je je les ai pas. Je
suis désolé. L'information en France
n'est pas n'est pas à la hauteur
de ce que devrait avoir. Le le français
est mal informé
et donc le scientifique a du mal aussi
pour faire ses études.
Ah ben oui, moi je passe mon temps à
chercher. Vous savez, moi euh j'étais
habitué que pour faire une découverte,
il fallait faire des puiss
et et c'est que
quand on fait des qu'on a des échecs,
que améliore. Un gars qui a réussi toute
sa vie
comme Macron. Oui. Bon, enfin oui, quoi
qu'il a eu quelques échecs. Euh donc on
apprend que des échecs et
moi je je dis à mes petits enfants
puisque j'ai plus que des petits
enfants, je lui ai dit il faut que vous
fassiez des échecs, il faut que vous
fassiez des trous secs parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on apprend.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
gouvernement Macron ? Ben je mon
gouvernement Macron, moi je je lui
reproche beaucoup de choses, mais euh ce
que je je dis, les autres sont pires.
C'est qui les autres ?
Bah tout ce qui est ce qu'on pourrait
rêver d'autres. Donc si vous voulez, moi
le euh je dis que euh il devrait faire
mieux mais que les autres feraient pas
mieux. Donc moi je je quand je vote, je
vote pas pour, je vote contre. Je suis
désolé mais bon. Nicolas Mayan,
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
des voitures à hydrogène ? On reviendra
sur le pic pétrolier, les ressources un
peu plus tard. Euh la voiture à
hydrogène, c'est une vraie alternative
comparée à la voiture électrique. Est-ce
que il y a pas un peu de green washing
avec la voiture électrique ? Euh alors
on va juste replacer un peu quand on
parle de voiture électrique. Il y a
plusieurs types de voitures électriques.
Il y a les voitures électriques.
Voiture nucléaire,
la voiture à batterie effectivement qui
qui peut être nucléaire ou qui peut être
hydraulique ou qui peut être au charbon,
ça dépend de là où vous habitez. Donc ça
c'est que des batteries. Vous avez ce
qu'on appelle une voiture hybride
rechargeable. Donc ça c'est une voiture
qui a une petite batterie qui peut
rouler 30 40 50 km électriques et qui a
un moteur thermique pour pouvoir faire
des plus longues distances. Et puis
après vous avez la voiture à hydrogène
qui est une voiture électrique mais dans
laquelle en gros on fait le plein
d'hydrogène qui passe dans une pile à
combustible qui crée l'électricité.
Euh et donc ça ça a toujours été ça a
toujours été la solution ultime. Alors
je vais raconter une anecdote quand j'ai
commencé à travailler sur ce sujet-là,
c'était il y a 10 ans et je travaillais
sur les moteurs électriques dans les
roues. J'ai rencontré un patron chez
Peugeot qui travaille sur ce sujet
depuis Norbert l'Arctique qui
travaillait depuis 40 ans sur le sujet
et quand je suis arrivé que je lui ai
posé la même question, il m'a dit "Vous
savez c'est un peu comme le pic
pétrolier il y a 40 ans on nous disait
que la voiture pile à combustible était
pour dans 40 ans et aujourd'hui c'est
toujours le cas." Alors pourquoi la pile
la voiture a pile à combustible ? tout
autour de cette table, nous allons pas
la conduire demain parce que il y a une
contrainte, c'est que l'hydrogène, il
faut le produire. Ça n'existe pas.
Alors les gens vous disent "Oui, mais
c'est c'est l'eau l'hydrogène." Oui,
c'est l'eau. Sauf qu'il faut casser la
molécule en deux et que ça consomme
beaucoup d'énergie. Aujourd'hui,
l'hydrogène on on le fabrique à 95 % à
partir d'énergie fossile. 50 % du gaz,
30 % du pétrole et le reste qui doit
être du charbon. Donc de l'hydrogène. Il
faudrait de l'hydrogène vert. Et comment
est-ce qu'on fabrique cet hydrogène vert
? On va vous dire bah oui ben avec des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes. Bah
les panneaux solaires et des éoliennes
aujourd'hui on y est c'est c'est des
coûts qui sont assez importants et ça un
petit peu compliqué pour produire cet
hydrogène.
Ben c'est surtout l'intermittence. Le le
le
l'éolien c'est 23 % et le solaire 11 %
en France hein. Donc le reste du temps
qu'est-ce qu' fabrique ? Alors le
premier problème donc hydrogène faut le
produire et le deuxème problème il faut
faire le plein.
Alors au-delà du fait qu'il y a une
station hydrogène qui a explosé la
semaine dernière en Norvège qui est pas
complètement rassurant,
une station c'est 1 million d'euros. Un
pistolet euh un pistolet pour mettre de
l'essence c'est 10000 €. Un pistolet
pour mettre de l'électricité c'est 20
30000 €. Donc si vous deviez mailler
l'ensemble du réseau français 400
stations d'autoroute 10 pistolets par
station. vous faites le calcul, vous
arrivez à 5 milliards d'euros. Donc ça
coûte cher. Et qui va payer 5 milliards
? Bah peut-être vous. Moi, j'ai pas
forcément envie de les payer. Et donc
aujourd'hui, on a cette contrainte là
qui fait que ce soit sur une voiture
électrique à batterie ou voiture
hydrogène, je suis sceptique sur le fait
que ces voitures là, on va faire des
longues distances avec. Donc l'hydrogène
pas dans les voitures. Par contre ça
peut être intelligent en ville parce que
quand on parle beaucoup de voiture
électrique mais ce qui est intéressant
sur l' voiture électrique ou le
transport électrique c'est que ça ne met
pas de pollution, il a pas de pot
d'échappement et donc
ça ça délocalise la pollution.
Ça la délocalise mais c'est ce qu'on
sait faire très bien depuis longtemps et
et ça fonctionne
et c'est plutôt une ça reste une bonne
chose.
Si qu'est-ce qui pollue en ville ? Oui,
il y a les voitures mais qu'est-ce qui
pollue aussi ? les bus. Donc les bus, il
y a des solutions de bus à hydrogène.
Les camionnettes,
les taxis, vous avez d'ailleurs des taxi
hydrogène à Paris, les Uber. En fait,
l'hydrogène comme la voiture électrique,
il faut que ce soit beaucoup utilisé.
Comme ça, vous pouvez amortir le coût,
le surcoup et comme ça, vous pouvez
amortir le coût du du ravitaillement, de
la recharge. Donc, en ville sur des
flottes, ça peut faire du sens. Pour
pour tous les Français, pour ceux qui
nous regardent, a priori vousz pas en
voiture hydrogène, sauf si c'est un
taxi.
Jean ?
Oui.
Quand vous voyez des trottinettes
électriques dans les rues de Paris,
ben je vis à la campagne. Moi, je viens
très pas souvent à Paris.
Il y a des chanceux ici.
Mais mais Oui, oui, oui, mais je le vois
à la télévision. Bon, bon, ce qu'il y a
moi moi moi ma réflexion, c'est que je
regarde toujours le passé parce que je
dis que hein, il faut regarder le passé.
Le premier moteur à explosion interne,
ça a été Isaac de Rocha en Suisse en
1805. C'était avec un gas à hydrogène.
Vous voyez ? Donc il y avait déjà
l'hydrogène.
La première voiture électrique, la
première voiture à dépenser les 100 km à
l'heure. C'est en 1898. jamais la
contente.
C'était une voiture électrique. En 1900,
en 1900, tout le monde vous disait "Le
futur, c'est la voiture électrique."
Mais le problème ça a été la batterie.
Et la batterie, la batterie que vous
utilisez dans votre voiture c'est celle
de il y a il y a 100 ans hein. Vo passé
au litium au PL.
Oui. Lithium. Mais oui, mais le lithium
ça explose hein.
Et puis euh
le lithium c'est ça va être aussi aussi
cher que le le pétrole hein et aussi
rare. Donc là aussi et puis je suis
désolé mais moi à chaque fois je râle
contre ces batteries qui qu'il faut
recharger. Il faut que je recharge mon
téléphone portable tout le temps. On est
tributaire d'une prise et cetera. Vous
ne réalisez pas,
vous ne pouvez pas,
je dirais moi qui rencontré traverser
tous les déserts, euh c'est grâce grâce
au pétrole et grâce hein le Sahara et
cetera au 44 à la guerre.
l'exploration du Sahara il y avait eu
les machines de Citroë avec les les
chenillettes mais ça c'était très
c'était les Jeeps et les 44 c'est pareil
le monde le monde agricole c'est s'est
modernisé à la suite des guerres utilis
là la com vous vous transportez vous
transportez
vous partez dans le désert pour un mois
il suffit de prendre d'avoir deux ou
trois barils dans l'arrière avec une
voiture électrique ou une voiture
hydrogène.
Vous avez rencontré le commandant
Coustau ?
Non non non non.
C'est de la prospection un peu
pétrolière lui au tout départ. Non, j'ai
pas cont
de ces trucs c'était
laxe. Laxe
avec de l'OSE et qui a fait donc
ça a été les premiers qui ont été
plongés qui ont qui ont plongé par 500 m
de profondeur avec des mélanges bizarres
de d'hydrogène et d'hélium. Et
maintenant la commerce s'est
complètement convertie qui a fait sa
fortune avec les pétroliers et
maintenant il faut il construit des
trucs pour le pour Mars et cetera. Mais
moi quand je euh j'étais au au Canada,
donc je m'occupais de d'explorer les euh
le le Grand Nord mais aussi les récifs
auirens et j'étais très intéressé par
l'offshore du du Labrador et on a
j'avais pris un permis avec Tenco comme
opérateur qui en forêt. Il av commencé à
forer et puis est arrivé une grande
tempête avec un iceberg. Alors tous les
gars, c'étaient des bateaux qui étaient
ancrés. Ils ont coupé au chalumeau les
ancres et puis ils se sont partis, ils
sont carapatés
et et l'asberg est passé. Donc comme
Total a été le premier à concevoir pour
l'offshore, il fallait aller profond et
cetera, ce qu'on appelle des bateaux à
position nonamique, c'est-à-dire vous
n'encrez plus, vous avez vos vosos vos
vos moteurs qui qui qui travaillent euh
pour rester à la verticale du puit. on
avait plus besoin d'encage. Donc on a
réussi à à garder l'opér l'opérateurship
de au Labrador et on a été reforé avec
le premier bateau à poser unement
dynamique au Labrador. Je quand je suis
allé sur la plateforme, c'était par 200
m d'eau, il faisait froid et quand j'ai
vu les gars de la qui plongeait, je suis
dit plutôt heux que moi. Et pourtant
pourant je donc donc
j'ai pas connu le commandant Coutau mais
euh dans mes
je dirais
tout toutes mes recherches dans les
Sarales, il faut on est toujours placé.
Moi à Alger, j'ai j'ai explosé le Sara
Alger. Alger
j'ai fait beaucoup de péchou marine à
Alger quand j'étais enid
là aussi j'ai fait aussi
j'ai fait de la pêche sous-marine sans
bouteille.
J'ai fait j'ai fait la pêche sous-marine
sans bouteille.
Sans bouteille c'était sans bouteille
à la gâchon.
Voilà voilà.
Nicolas Mayant les gaz de chiste, ça
coûte un peu de pognon aux exploitants
en ce moment là. Est-ce que c'est viable
à plus long terme ? Alors, je pense
qu'il faut effectivement parler un peu
de ça parce que j'en parlé du pic
pétrolier du pic convention de pétrole
conventionnel 75 % de la production de
pétrole qui a été passée reconnue par
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie en
2008. Et donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
après ? Vous avez eu des prix du pétrole
élevé entre 2011 et 2014. Vous avez eu
beaucoup d'argent disponibles aux
États-Unis avec les politiques
monétaires et donc on a développé cette
nouvelle industrie de pétrole
conventionnel, pétrole de Rochem et qui
a repoussé qui nous a donné un peu de un
peu d'air ou la dernière picous qui a
repoussé le pic pétrolier à d'autres
horizons. Ça a commencé avec le gaz, ça
a continué avec le pétrole. Euh alors
deux choses différentes, on va parler du
gaz d'abord euh le gaz de chis qui est
quand même intéressant effectivement que
ce soit gaz ou pétrole, c'est que c'est
quelque chose sur lesquels les
pétroliers ne gagnent pas beaucoup
d'argent. Un chiffre récent de Ristat
qui parlait que 90 % des entreprises du
secteur
ne gagnaient pas d'argent. C'est-à-dire
que leur coût euh leur bénéfice,
l'argent qui gagnait était plus faible
que ce qu'ils investissaient. Euh et
aujourd'hui, alors un truc quand même
drôle sur le gaz de chisse très
rapidement, notamment sur la position
française. Vous savez que la France a
refusé et a interdit l'extraction du gaz
et du pétrole de chiste.
Par contre, en mars dernier, pour ceux
qui s intéressent sur le le site de
département américain de l'énergie, vous
verrez que la France a été champion du
monde, le plus grand importateur de gaz
liquéfié. Euh et dans le gaz liquéfié
américain, vous avez 70 % de gaz de
chiste.
Alors, petite remarque hein, quand on
parle de la plupart des termes employés,
vous avez entendu parler des chistes
bitumineux.
Ce n'est ni deschistes ni duitume. C'est
du kérogène immatur qui ont été
exploités avec les chistes d'autres
chauffant. Il faut chauffer, il faut
faire donc c'est du kéroène la immature,
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut faire une
pyrolise, donc il faut chauffer. Ils
sont utilisé par exemple en Estonie pour
faire marcher les centrales et ces
centrales comme de la tourbe. C'est
comme de la tourbe. Ou alors on peut le
transformer en pétrole en chauffant à
600°.
Parce que si vous voulez la nature fait
cette pyrolyse du kérogène avec en
profondeur avec entre 50 et et 100°gr et
quelques millions d'années et la
pression température si vous voulez.
Donc les chistes bitumineux c'est ni des
chistes ni du bitume. Le gaz de chiste,
c'est pas ça vient pas des chistes, ça
vient de cré comme le pétrole de chiste
ou de rochemaire. C'est pas du tout donc
la rocher, ça vient du réservoir compact
à côté de la rochemire qui est alimenté
hein et que l'on produit grâce à des
fissures qu'il faut euh
ouvrir et maintenir ouverte par du
sable. Vous savez combien maintenant
tout un tas d'autres saloperies hein.
Oui, mais enfin rien que de sable, rien
que de sable. Donc pour faire une
fracturation, il vous faut 40 camions
pour maintenir la pression, pour envoyer
suffisamment de pression. Il vous faut
une centaine de de camions qui vous
amènent d'eau et et il vous faut
maintenant avec les trucs performant il
faut en moyenne le record qui a été fait
dans un puit pétrolier l'ancien un puit
gazier 22000 tonnes de sable
et c'est du sable normal ? Non, pas du
tout. C'est un sable bien calibré qui
vient du Michigan qui est moi mon sable
dans ma campagne, c'est 25 € la tonne.
Là, c'est du 100 € la tonne, hein. Et
puis c'est des centaines de camions
defin de de wagons de train.
Or, si vous voulez
ce qu'il a tout le monde dit puisque aux
États-Unis
le pétrole de chiste et le gaz de chiste
est aussi performant, il y a aucune
raison que ça soit pas dans le reste du
monde pareil. Bon euh seulement si vous
voulez tout le monde oublie que le
système minier
aux États-Unis est complètement
différent du reste du monde hein. Au aux
États-Unis, le propriétaire du terrain
est propriétaire du sous-sol. Donc tous
les exp les les gars qui qui ont toutent
parce que si vous voulez les nuisances
de la fracturation. Bon je vous parle
pas des tremblements de terre, je vous
parle pas des trucs bidons comme les les
arrivées de gaz qui sont qui bon c'est
c'est pas
Pourquoi c'est bidon ça ?
Mais parce que ça venait ça venait pas
du tout des profondeurs parce que c'est
pas vrai, ça venait de de de gaz de de
surface et cetera parce que
ça faisait bien de de
l'hydrofracturation.
Non non non non non non.
Vous avez des sources ? Ah bah oui,
demander à un pétrolier sérieux, il vous
dira non écologiste sérieux,
non. Le le le Gaseland là, le le le film
qui vous montrez, on on allumait le
truc. Non, ça venait pas. Ça venait pas
parce que de toute façon
et l'eau contaminée ? L'eau contaminée.
Ah ben l'eau contaminée. Oui. Oui. Non
mais ça il y a il y a des mauvais, il y
a des gars qui font pas le le boulot.
Non non mais ça je suis d'accord. Donc
je vous dis
qu'est-ce que vous entendez qu'ils font
pas le boulot ? Mais parce que il y a il
y a beaucoup il y a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de quand vous cette taux taux
que vous injectez hein des centaines de
bon de de camions, elle revient à la
surface et il faut normalement hein la
recollecter
la la recollecter, la purifier et cetera
mais des gens qui sont au de temp ils la
jettent dans le dans le ruisseau alors
qu'il devraient pas mais ils violent la
loi. Bon non mais pour pour revenir pour
revenir à l'heure actuelle, toutes les
nuisances que vous avez aux États-Unis
sont accepté par les locaux parce que
eux hein quand il ils louent leur terre
au pétroli ils touchent déjà
pour signer le contrat à peu près 10
fois le prix que vaut le terrain en
surface
plus les royalties sur la production.
Donc eux, ils acceptent toutes les
pollutions, hein, et toutes les trucs
parce qu'ils sont intéressés. Et vous
avez, il y a eu un très bon documentaire
qui s'est fait euh qui s'est fait que
j'ai vu il y a 2 mois, deux ou 3 mois,
c'est le gaz de houille
en Australie. Et en Australie,
donc au Queensland, vous avez du gaz de
houille, donc le Grisou hein, qui est
exploité par des gaziers.
Mais les propriétaires du terrain qui
ont essayé de lutter, hein, ils n'ont
ils n'ont droit à rien. Mais les grands
les grands, je dirais bénéficiaires,
c'est les gaziers qui produisent ce gaz
de houille et le gouvernement.
Et donc les gars ont lutté pendant des
années, maintenant ils ont abandonné et
cetera. Donc dans tout le reste du monde
euh il y a le ce qu'on appelle nimbai
not inmanyard.
Il y a les locaux qui se sont par
exemple quand les Algériens ont voulu
produire le gaz disochiste à Insala, il
y a les gars d'Insala qui ont protesté
et qui ont empêché les sonatraque euh de
produire. Bon, je vous parle pas. Alors
donc je vous dis dans le reste du monde
d'abord ils ont essayé en France on a
interdit, on a même pas essayé alors
qu'on aurait dû faire l'inventaire. Mais
non, en France on a nos nos écolos
religieux qui Bon
Pourquoi vous dites écolos religieux ?
Mais parce que ils ne raisonnent pas.
Ils ne raisonnent pas. Et si vous
voulez, moi je suis désolé quand ils
sont contre le nucléaire, le nucléaire
ne tue pas.
Tout de suite.
Oui. Oui. Non, il y a il y a pas eu un
seul mort. Nucléri par contre les les
barrages ça a tué mal placé c'était 150
personnes. Je vous parle pas il y a des
centaines de mon mort qui sont menenés
de des barrages qui se sont écroulés
mais ça on les a fait
un petit concert de thyroïde ça passe
mieux à la télé mais
mais mais les les gars qui vous disent
le nucléaire
c'est affreux. Il y a ça fait 50 ans
qu'on a un nucléaire en France, il y a
pas un seul mort. et et toutes les
grandes choses qui se sont passées.
Tchernobyl c'est une grande connerie
hein. Les militaires voulaient voir ce
qui se passait. Ils ont des désamorcer
toutes les alarmes et puis ils ont voulu
voir ce qui se passait. Ben ça a sauté.
Ils voulaient voir ce qui euh Fukushima.
Fukushima, tout le monde le sait qu'il y
a des des tsunamis mais euh les gens de
TPCO euh qui sont des bon euh
qui nous a qui nous a acheté notre Mox.
Ah,
c'est le Mox.
Ah, peut-être oui, peut-être oui.
Oui, oui. C'est l'uranium enrichi et
avec du
polonium. Oui, mais en tout cas les les
gars les gars de Tebo, pour faire des
économies de pompage d'eau,
la falaise était à 30 m de hauteur.
Ils ont rabaissé,
descendu la centrale à 10 m
pour moins pomper.
Faut moins pomper pour faire des
économies de pompage. Mais bon, ça je
veux bien. Mais les générateurs qui
étaient qui étaient là, ils ont laissé à
côté. Alors hein là il y avait aucune
hein un câble de 20 m ça vous prend pas
de l'énergie
50 ans 50 ans à l'échelle géologique
c'est rien quand on dit que le nucléaire
tue pas tout de suite.
Mais non mais le nucléaire mais je suis
désolé tout le tous les lesés Non mais
le le l'uranium que l'on a qui vient des
gens il était il était dans la nature.
on en a ajouté un peu mais mais les
remettres, moi je je me souviens que là
quand quand je j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser, hein, il y avait dans les
ros, il y avait des endroits où tout le
monde savait que il y avait tellement
d'uranium hein, que les les plantes
changaient de couleur, c'était bizarre
et cetera et personne ne mettait
d'habitation. C'était connu qu'il
fallait pas mettre une habitation là. On
allait chasser le sapin parce que là
mais maintenant il y a plus de tous ces
trucs là puisque on a récolté de
l'uranium, on l'a on l'a on l' on l'a
extrait et on l'a mis dans nos
centrales.
On l'a un peu enrichi entre-temps.
On l'a un peu enrichi mais oui. Mais
mais tout ça tout ça moi je suis
la demie de l'uranium c'est combien ?
Non mais tous ces trucs-là hein, il
suffit de les remettre dans un endroit
où on est sûr que ça bouge pas. Et à
Bur, je vous assure que ça bougera pas.
Je suis géologue, hein. Bon,
pourquoi ça bougera pas ?
Mais pas parce que ça pas bougé depuis
100 millions d'années. Je vois pas
pourquoi ça bougerait puisque bon. Donc
moi, je suis désolé, je suis un
géologue, je raisonne en millions
d'années.
Et quand on vous dit on vous dit tout le
monde changement climatique, c'est
affreux. On en parle pas. Non,
non. Si on en parle, on en parle.
On en parle. Bon, moi je dis je veux
bien mais je regarde l'histoire. Si vous
écoutez le le roi Merlin ou si vous
voulez tout le monde sait que en l'an
hein les Vikings avaient des élevé des
vaches au Grenland
et qu'il y avait de la vigne à Londres
et que hein après il y a le petit âge
glacière qui a commencé à 1350 et
qui a duré jusqu'en 1850. La révolution
française, c'est dû à quoi ? Ça est dû à
des mauvaises récoltes, changement
climatique et et les l'éruption
volcanique du laqui en Islande. Donc les
gens qui vous disent il ne faut plus
qu'il y a de changement climatique mais
lequel ils veulent y revenir le
changement climatique de de 1800 en en
1800 la la
scène gelée tous les ans. Ouais mais
d'accord.
Si je vous dis changement climatique,
ça fait dégeler le permafrost
ou
et comme nos pétroliers sont très
intelligents, ils nous ont mis des
oléoduc vissé sur du permafrost qui se
casse la gueule et qui fait qui qui fait
dérailler les oléod.
Enfin, je suis désolé, le permafrost il
est là depuis vous savez que euh nous
sommes en période de glaciation depuis 3
millions d'années. Vous savez ça
hein ? Il y a 3 millions d'années,
il y avait pas de glaciation parce que
il n'y avait pas de continent de de
continent enfin si vous voulez c'est la
dée des continents qui a ramené hein en
changeant qui a ramené des continents
autour du pôle nord et au pôle sud. Au
crété, il y avait pas de de de glace au
pôle nord.
C'est pour ça que la mer la mer était
150 m plus haut et que ici à à Paris, on
était dans la mer. C'est la plage.
C'était pas la plage. C'était là où vous
avez vous avez des règles. Donc je je
vous dis simplement les glaciations,
il faut augmenter à 300 millions
d'années pour retrouver des glaciations
dans le carbonifère. Et depuis 3
millions d'années, nous sommes
en en glaciation la plupart du temps et
il y a des périodes interglaciaire. Nous
sommes en période interglaciaire depuis
10000 ans. La dernière hein, tout ça
c'est dû hein au cycle de Milankovic
hein astronomique. Bon donc nous sommes
enfin si vous voulez les
les pétroliers sont pas responsables du
gaz à effet de serre. C'est ça.
Non, je dis que le d'abord le gassa
effet de serre, je suis désolé mais
c'est pas le CO2 qui est le principal,
c'est des vaches.
C'est la Non, non, c'est pas la [__]
vache. C'est la la vapeur d'eau. Et
comme les gens ne savent pas, les
scientifiques
ne savent pas, je dirais quantifier
le l'effet des nuages et en plus de ça,
ils sont incapables parce que les
nuages, il faudrait actuellement tous
les
les scénarios du GC, c'est des
simulations, hein.
Vous avez un avis sur le JC ? Ah oui oui
oui puisque moi le GC le GC est basé moi
j'ai fait une conférence euh à Yasa.
Vous savez ce que c'est Yasa ? au moment
où Kennedy et Crouwchef ont,
c'était pour envoyer les les
scientifiques discuter en dehors.
Voilà donc ils ont créé il y a ça à
Lassenburg Vienne c'était International
Application of donc pendant la guerre au
froide il y avait un endroit dans le
monde où vous avez des Américains et des
Russes qui travaillaient ensemble et il
travaillaient sur le futur hein làin de
de la planète. Donc tous les scénarios
du GC ont été conçus à Yasa par un gars
qui s'appelle Nasizenovic
et qui à ce moment-là en en 95 ils ont
conçu des scénarios et c'était des
scénarios qui ont été conçus par des
économistes sans aucune réalité. Donc il
y avait un gars qui disent "Oh la
population elle peut être à 7 milliards
en 2050." Ah non, elle peut être à 17 à
15 et cetera.
Ils ont fait des des scénarios
énergétiques qui n'ont aucun sens et
c'est toujours ces scénarios qui sont
envisagés parce que c'est à ce moment-là
via
le le le Nations- Unies, il faut avoir
l'unanimité. Donc ils ont eu l'animité
sur des scénarios qui étaient absolument
irréalistes. Moi j'ai fait un papier à
Yasa en 2001 et il y avait
hein et euh
papier disait
et ben qui qui qui disait qu'il y avait
avoir un pic pétrolier et que et que
scénario était. J'ai été à Vienne en
2005 je crois c'était le le le la
réunion des des scientifiques j'ai
rencontré Joussell je lui dis vos
scénarios
Jean Jocel Oui oui. Donc il faisait une
présentation moi je faisais aussi une
autre. J'étais le voir, je dis vos
scénarios, ils sont ils sont
complètement irralistes. Ils n'ont rien
à voir avec ce que prédisent les grands
experts, la IE, bon et cetera. Il faut
les changer. Ah, il m'a dit "On a pas le
temps pour le prochain rapport mais on
le fera." Alors, qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait ? Donc, tous les anciens, c'était
des des scénarios, il y avait les 40
scénarios, c'est hein. Vous n'avez qu'à
voir mes graphiques que je l'ai vu et
que qui montre qu'ils sont en plein et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ? Ils les ont
remplacé. He maintenant il vous donne
des ce qu'ils appellent du forçage
radiatif donc c'est des wattes par mètre
carré. Donc, ils ont remplacé les 40
scénarios par quatre scénarios qui sont
euh 8 5 6 euh 4 5 et 2. Et le 2, il est
complètement iréaliste et les deux
autres réalistes. Il y a qu'un seul qui
Mais quand les gars vous disent les
rapports du GC,
si je résume correctement, le GC pour
vous n'est pas assez alarmiste.
Non, mais ils ont ils ont des scénarios
le 4 degrés, il est complètement
irréaliste. Il y a qu'à voir
Pourquoi il irréaliste ? Mais parce
qu'il est réaliste leur scénario
énergétique, ils sont complètement en
dehors de ce qui est possible.
Il y a il y a il y a des moi je je fais
des tas de scénarios qui sont plus
pessimistes que que la IE mais qui
prennent ce de la qui sont très
optimistes et ils verront que
ils sont complètement là. Puis c'est pas
difficile,
il faut s'attendre à quoi ?
Il faut s'attendre à que personne ne
sait que sera le climat, c'est tout.
personne ne peut prévoir. C'est pas
difficile. Il y a eu des des des
rapports qui ont été fait James Hansen.
Donc vous êtes climatosceptique ou
moi je suis pas je suis climatoceptique
en en disant simplement que on est
incapable de prévoir le climat et que
les rapports
les scénarios du G. Mais alors c'est pas
difficile. James Hanson a fait ces mêmes
scénarios en 98
et il a donné ses prévisions pour 2000
aujourd'hui. Allez voir mes papiers et
vous direz il avait fait trois
scénarios.
Il y en a deux qui sont complètement,
on devait être 3°gr supérieur et il y en
a un qui est qui colle avec la réalité
la température telle qu'elle est mesurée
hein par les satellites parce que je
parle pas des stations qui sont plus ou
moins parce que vous savez que le les
stations quand elles étaient mesurées à
un moment il faisait très froid parce
que il y avait beaucoup de scientifiques
dans les goulaces donc il y avait
beaucoup de mesures qui étaient fait
dans les goulags. Maintenant, il y a
plus personne dans les goulag pour
mesurer les températures de froid en
Sibérie. Donc le nombre de de stations
et cetera. Mais enfin pour revenir les
prévisions d'en
sur les trois, il y en avait une de
bonne et celle qui était bonne il sa
prévision c'était pour une une
composition du CO2 qui était de 350 ppm
et on est à 400.
Donc leur scénario, si vous regardez les
prévisions anciennes pour aujourd'hui,
elles sont fausses. Et si vous regardez
toutes les prévisions qu'ils ont fait et
cetera, ils sont complètement en dehors
des des mesures actuelles.
Donc il faut faut s'attendre à pire.
Non, il faut s'attendre à à je ne sais
pas. Je ne sais pas. Moi moi tout ce que
je sais c'est que dans
c'est que je ne sais rien.
C'est que je sais rien si hein. C'est
c'est si vous voulez c'est un une phrase
c'était Jean Gabin. Plus je sais plus je
ne sais pas hein. Et moi je je j'ai dit
hein
c'est un peu plus grave que et je dis
plus je sais plus je ne sais pas et les
autres non plus. J'ai ajouté
euh Nicolas Millant qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez de ça ? Des prévisions du GC
par rapport à l'énergie. Alors, vous
savez, il y a deux il y a deux types de
de scientifiques qui sont pas forcément
d'accord et qui s'opposent. Vous avez
les gens qu'on appelle les climatologues
et qui disent que le CO2
est la chose qui va le plus nous
concerner. Et puis vous avez ce qu'on
appelle les piquistes comme gens et
d'autres d'autres personnes qui vont
dire "Non, la contrainte, elle va venir
du pic pétrolier."
Je crois qu'aujourd'hui il se trouve que
les émissions de CO2 de l'homme, elles
viennent principalement
elles viennent principalement du pétrole
et des fossiles. Donc entre guillemets,
ça tombe bien parce que c'est ces gens
se retrouvent sur ce combat là. Euh moi
personnellement, je pense que quand je
vois ce que l'homme est capable de faire
dans l'aire de l'entropocène, que ce
soit sur les océans, sur ce qui nous
entoure,
la biodiversité,
euh il ne me semble pas inconcevable
qu'il puisse avoir un un impact sur le
climat. La la discussion, c'est de
savoir est-ce que l'homme c'est lui qui
rajoute la goutte, qui fait déborder le
vase et qui fait diverger diverger le
climat. Moi, je suis plus préoccupé
personnellement euh par
cette contrainte au niveau de l'énergie
parce qu'une contrainte énergie telle
qu'on on devrait la rencontrer dans dans
les prochaines années, que ce soit sur
le surtout sur le pétrole, pour moi
c'est assez rapidement la guerre civile.
Donc c'est vraiment ça qui me alors ça
tombe bien, c'est en France par exemple
66 % des émissions de CO2, c'est le
pétrole. Donc si on arrive à faire
baisser ces émissions de CO2, on fera
baisser la consommation de pétrole et
entre guillemets pour moi c'est le même
combat et donc tout le monde sera
content. Je suis
moi moi le principal reproche que je
fais au je dirais aux écolos, c'est
qu'ils sont complètement axés sur CO2.
Moi j'ai il y a longtemps que j'ai écrit
en disant le CO2 le CO2 le CO2 ne tue
pas mais les particules que tuent.
Qu'est-ce que font les écolos à l'actuel
sur les sur les particules ? Rien.
Si, ils braillent beaucoup sur les
particules.
Ben il braille. Oui, mais enfin, il y a
il y a il y a a y a y a il y a il y a un
an ou deux, moi aller voir mes écrits,
ça fait 10 ans que je gueule sur les
particules et sur le diesel. Moi, j'ai
jamais acheté une voiture diesel. Moi,
moi je j'ai été écolo. Moi je suis
désolé. Moi, j'ai fait isoler ma maison
de campagne il y a 20 ans. J'ai déjà
renouvelé dans l'isolation des combes au
bout de 20 ans. Donc moi, j'ai j'ai déjà
p chaleur géothermique. Donc
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans votre
action de tous les jours pour protéger
la planète mis à part la rénovation de
votre isolation ? Vous mangez de la
viande ? Oui, parce que j'en mange un
peu mais pas beaucoup parce que je je
j'assume euh mon état humain de
d'omnivore. Je suis désolé hein, nos
ancêtres ont mangaient de la viande et
on est on est des omnivores. Et que bon,
alors je respecte ceux qui disent bon
que qui veulent pas manger de viande
mais bon que moi pendant la guerre je
récoltais du miel des des seins
sauvages. Je chassais le mer à la
fronde. Moi, j'ai tué des merles à la
fronte. Il y a pas beaucoup de gars qui
ont tué des merles à la fronte. C'est
pas facile avec une fronte de tuer.
Ouais, nous on fait que la galinette
Sendré.
C'est la galinette Sendré.
Non.
C'est très difficile à chasser. Il faut
faut des années de pratique pour la
galinette Sendré.
Ah bon ? Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
encore ?
Nicolas Mayant.
La galinette Sendré, ça vous intéresse
un peu ?
Ça me parle peut-être un peu plus.
Ouais.
Euh le GC, on on va on va passer sur le
GC. J'en parle des particules. Vous avez
fait un papier qui s'était fait décrier
par le monde et son décodex sur le le
transfert de particules de pays
producteur à à notre espace aérien.
Ça, on est où ça ? Est-ce que les
journalistes, les pouvoirs publics ont
compris un peu votre papier ou pas ? Ou
est-ce que votre papier était totalement
faux ? Alors aujourd'hui, on a on a un
vrai souci euh en Europe et dans les
grandes villes. Je prends l'exemple de
Paris, c'est que en Paris à Paris, vous
avez une mère qui s'appelle Annie d'Algo
qui depuis qu'elle est là depuis 2014 a
une politique assez volontariste
notamment pour réduire la pollution.
elle a annoncé euh la réduction
des véhicules diesel et l'interdiction
2024 et puis c'est et puis 2030 toutes
les voiture. Euh et donc c'est des
bonnes choses parce que c'est vrai que
quand on est en ville et que vous
marchez dans la rue comme moi, quand
vous respirez, vous sentez bien que la
particule, elle vient plutôt du pot
d'échappement du scooter et de la
voiture que de la satrale à charbon qui
est basée en Allemagne.
Donc c'est une bonne chose et en ville
les sources de pollution ce sont les
voitures, essence diesel et les et le
feu de bois aussi. Donc ça il faut le
réduire clairement mais ce qu'on se rend
compte c'est que depuis 5 ans à Paris la
pollution ne baisse plus.
Donc ça veut dire que les voitures sont
de plus en plus récentes. Donc elle
polluent de moins en moins en tout cas
sur les particules puisque les voitures
euh diesel sont équipé de filtre à
particules mais les nivea
ça c'est avant où qu'on les trafique ou
pas ?
Non non avant qu'on les trafique mais
néanmoins les niveaux de particules
baissent pas. Donc il y a deux autres
sources possibles. Les voitures essence,
on s'est rendu compte en fait que les
voitures essence émettaient aussi
beaucoup de particules qui sont plus
petites, 60 nanomè. Donc on parle de
particules ultra fines. Et aussi on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
contribution importante de particules ce
qu'on appelle secondaires. Donc qui ne
se sont pas formés forcément à Paris,
qui sont formés ailleurs en France ou
ailleurs dans d'autres pays. Et donc
vous avez plusieurs contributeurs en
fait. Donc en gros, comment ça marche
une particule secondaire ? Vous avez
deux sources. Il vous faut de
l'ammoniaque et l'ammoniaque, il est
principalement issu de l'agriculture.
D'accord ? Et après, il vous faut soit
du dioxyde de soufre émis par les
navires. Le port de Rotterdame par
exemple, c'est un le réacteur de la
pollution européenne. On a beaucoup de
particules dont l'origine vient de vient
de Rotard Dam.
et
peut tracer les particules.
Les particules, vous avez des modèles
qui existent au niveau européen où on
voit à quel endroit elles sont émises,
on voit comment elles fonctionnent et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'avais utilisé
quand j'avais eu mes échanges cordiaux
avec le Mondre pour montrer
qu'effectivement on avait eu bien eu ce
nuage de particules qui qui avait
traversé la France. Euh donc on sait les
identifier. Euh
aujourd'hui, c'est un problème qu'on
devrait traiter euh au niveau européen.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? veut dire
fermer les centrales thermiques,
notamment les centrales à charbon. Il y
en a pas que en Allemagne, il y en a
aussi beaucoup en Pologne où elles sont
plus vieilles, où elles émettent encore
plus de particules. Et puis vous avez le
problème du dioxyde d'azote. Et là,
qu'est-ce qui éit le dioxyde d'azote ?
Vous avez encore ces centrales, un
charbon thermique, vous avez
l'industrie, vous avez aussi encore les
bateaux, les bateaux qui émettent
beaucoup que ce soit à Rotterdam, mais
aussi dans en Méditerranée hein pour
ceux qui qui vont sur la côte d'Azur,
ils doivent pouvoir s'en rendre compte
de temps en temps. Et puis après, vous
avez surtout les voitures et les
voitures diesel, un très le scandale
Volkswagen, c'est le dioxyde d'azote. Et
donc aujourd'hui, on n pas vraiment
beaucoup de politiques qui sont mis en
place. Je rappelle juste euh une
anecdote, hein. La France euh sur le
dioxyde d'azote euh a été euh et a été
euh
enfin assigné en justice hein devant la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne.
Pour l'instant euh rien rien n'est fait
rien n'est fait pour que ce problème
soit soit résolu.
Moi moi je
j'ouvre une parenthèse de la part de la
communauté qui nous fait remonter une
information. François Deuger a annoncé
aujourd'hui la mise en place d'un super
calculateur afin d'améliorer les
prévisions météo pour un investissement
de 150 millions d'euros.
Jean à vous.
Oui. Non, simplement je voulais dire que
là aussi quand on parle de pollution par
exemple, on vous dit les Chinois, ils
sont d'accord pour pour euh pour
l'accord de Paris et pour la pollution.
Euh tout tout le monde pense que c'est
le CO2, mais les Chinois euh le CO2, ils
s'en préoccupent pas. De toute façon,
ils ont accepté l'accord de Paris, mais
c'est les émissions de CO2 par rapport à
leur PIB et comme leur PIB beaucoup plus
que le truc, donc ils se sont engagés à
rien. Mais les Chinois, ils n'ont qu'une
idée en tête. C'est pas le CO2, c'est
les particules. Vous savez, c'est ABC,
c'est asiatique Brown Cloud qui couvre
toute la Chine et les Indes. C'est une
pollution comme il y avait le fog à
Londres qui était dû au bois de
chauffage. C'était pas du tout de CO2
hein, c'était de la su et là c'est hein
c'est des particules et donc c'est pas
du tout le CO2 qui les préoccupe les
Chinois.
Ils sont préoccupés à court terme pour
leur leurs conditions sanitaires de leur
population. C'est ça
exactement. Ben de d'avoir c'est
irrespirable maintenant que le Pékin la
plupart du temps.
Une question d'internet. À qui profite
la nouvelle économie verte ?
À qui profite la nouvelle économie verte
?
Est-ce qu'il y a déjà une économie verte
J'imagine que dans l'économie verte, on
va mettre les panneaux solaires, les
éoliennes, les voitures électriques.
Alors, les voitures électriques
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes Renault et
que vous vendez une voiture, vous gagnez
pas beaucoup d'argent. C'est pour ça que
les constructeurs européens, ils vendent
pas beaucoup de voitures électriques
parce que ils gagnent beaucoup moins
d'argent que de vendre une voiture à
essence ou diesel. Euh alors
aujourd'hui, il y a un certain nombre
d'acteurs peut-être qui vont lever de
l'argent. Tesla a lever beaucoup
d'argent.
Maintenant, combien de temps ça va durer
? On a beaucoup de pays où les
subventions, que ce soit sur les
inagères renouvelables éoliens, solaire
ou les voitures électriques commencent à
diminuer voir
des réacteurs aux algues. Vous qu'on
vous en pensez quoi ? Oui. Alors, ça
c'est des choses qui sont faites. Moi,
j'avais regardé le sujet il y a il y a 8
ans déjà. Donc, vous mettez euh dans de
l'eau et je crois que ça d'ailleurs
c'est un des problèmes dans de l'eau qui
doit être qui ne doit pas être salé.
Vous mettez des algues, des
microbactéries et du CO2, ça vous crée
de ça vous crée du carburant. Ça peut
être éventuellement une solution. Faut
voir à quel coût ça sort. Et puis c'est
toujours le problème de la dose et de
quelle échelle on peut obtenir avec ce
ce type de solution. Donc il y a des
gens qui travaillent là-dessus, on les
laisse on les laisse travailler et voir.
Il faut il faut juste rappeler que le
pétrole ça coûte rien ça. Les gens ont
pas souvent en tête. On se dit le
pétrole 50 100 dollars. C'est la nature
qui a fait
je je prends je veux dire 50 c de
pétrole. Le pétrole ça coûte moins cher
que l'eau minérale. Les gens l'ont pas
forcément en tête. Il disent bah non
c'est vachement cher. 60 € dans ma
voiture non 1 L de pétrole c'est 1,50 €.
Avec les taxes on enlève les taxes et 50
centimes. Donc
il vaut plus taxer le coc.
ou ou le pétrole, je sais pas.
Jean Jean, on on va reparler du climat
parce que la communauté est un peu
Ah ben je je je
intéressé sur vos propos qui
Oui, mes propos de de géologues.
Moi je je connais des tas de géologues,
ils sont ils sont comme quoi parce que
ils ont ils ont étudié
la géologie et cetera. Et donc
l'anthropocène c'est
ben l'anthropocène bon c'est l'homme
l'homme qu'est-ce que c'est ? Bon,
maintenant on est remonté. C'est très
amusant parce que quand j'ai commencé un
peu ma m'intéresser à la science donc
c'était il y a très très longtemps,
l'homme de néanale était considéré comme
une bête primitive et cetera. Tandis que
maintenant on sait que euh nous avons
tous des aines de de néandertal. pas
tous pas tous les les Européens et les
asiatiques et euh et que et que donc moi
je je je raisonne sur
la façon dont par exemple
le l'homme
je regarde beaucoup je regarde plus les
les films parce que ça m'intéresse pas
par exemple les documentaires
suré
suré ou sur d'autres sur la la fin la
Fin par exemple des Mayas. Les Mayas
c'est du changement climatique qui les a
qui les a anéantis. Donc euh si vous
voulez, moi je surxoitation de leur
milieu hein.
Oui, mais enfin bon euh il y a beaucoup
de choses mais enfin donc pour moi pour
moi le le pour pour un un un géologue le
si vous voulez pendant
30 ans 30 non oui oui pendant 30 ans
j'étais géologue je cherchais ce qu'on
appelle des patates. Donc on fait les
structures puisque si vous voulez le
pétrolier hein, d'abord au début il
forait sur les endroits où il y avait
des suintements. Après il a vu qu'il y
avait des anti des clinau de surface qui
piégeaient le pétrole hein puisque si
vous voulez pas avoir du pétrole, il
faut avoir une rochemaire qui a été
enfuie suffisamment ce qu'on appelle la
fenêtre à huile hein. entre 3000 et
3000. Bon, c'est en température qu'il
faut dire. Et puis la fenêtre à gaz et
puis dessous c'est tout est cuit. Bon et
il faut avoir donc
une roche mer, il faut avoir un système
de de de de de
génération d'huile et il faut avoir une
structure
avec un réservoir et un truc imperméable
pour pour dessus. la connexion avec le
climat avec ça c'est
alors le climat bon pendant longtemps la
seule façon de chercher les structures
en profondeur notamment au Sahara parce
que les Sahara les Américains les
Français ont exploré les Américains n'en
voulaient pas ils disaient il y a pas de
d'indice en surface donc il n'y a pas
parce que si vous voulez dans le monde
vous avez à peu près 600 bassins
sédimentaires, vous n'avez que 200 qui
ont du pétrole parce qu'il faut avoir
ces conditions de génération
euh
il y en a en Chine un peu ou pas ? Non
comment
en Chine il y en a ? Ah bah bien sûr, il
y a des tas de de de de bassin
pétrolier, mais il y en a qui sont plus
ou moins plus ou moins bons. Enfin, ils
sont en déclins, hein, les les Chinois.
Non, mais pour pour revenir pour revenir
donc euh au au au au au au au
la la sismique vous cherche de des des
formes de euh structurales par en
envoyant des zes, hein. Vous envoyez des
z ondes, c'est comme l'échographie,
hein, hein, qui descendent et qui
reviennent qui reviennent quand ils
trouvent des des des
euh
des poches
des Non, non.
des roches à haute vitesse, c'est comme
des calcaires. Donc vous vous avez une
une roche calcaire, ça va vous renvoyer
hein les les ondes et vous vous
cherchez. Donc qu'est-ce que vous faites
la sismique hein ? le long de profil,
vous tirez hein. Alors vous engendrez
des ondes, c'était autrefois en tiré
maintenant on vibre et puis on on avec
des géophones, des sismographes, on on
donc on récupère ça et on voit la forme
de ces marqueurs sismiques. Donc moi
j'ai pendant 30 ans enfin 37 ans, j'ai
cherché j'ai suivi des marqueurs
sismiques et ce n'est qu'à la retraite
que j'ai réalisé que ces marqueurs
sismiques c'est des échangements
climatiques. Quand vous voyez vos vos
falaises de calcaire par exemple, moi
j'ai fait mes études de géologie à
Grenoble, l'urgonien et cetera, toutes
les grandes falaises, c'est du CO2 qui
était dans l'atmosphère qui se sont
déposés au fond de la mer et et qui a
fait et qui a fait du calcaire. Donc
c'est du changement climatique. Vous
avez le Allez voir mes papiers. Vous
avez euh le l'une des grands rochemers
qui est qui est connue en Argentine,
c'est la vacarta, la vache morte. C'est
une alternance de calcaire et de gris
qui font à peu près quand vous voyez une
alternance de tous les 20 cm grosso
modo, ben ça c'est le cycle de
précession des équinoxes de 20000 ans.
Donc ça fait 20000 ans. Donc vous voyez
une répétition
des équinox du système solaire
du système solaire. Vous avez les
Milankovic, c'est c'est trois trois
cycles. Vous avez les la précession des
desquinox, c'est 20000 ans. Vous avez
l'obliquité, c'est 40000 ans et vous
avez les les l'ellipse
de
de la terre, hein. Donc qui fait 100000
ans parce que vous avez vous avez les
glaciés, c'est tous les 100000 ans et
qui ne sont que depuis 3 millions
d'années. Il y a
donc pour résumer pour si je comprends
bien c'est quoi votre point de vue sur
mais mon point de vue c'est que je dis
moi le le changement climatique il y en
a eu depuis 4 milliards d'années que
pendant 37 ans moi j'en ai suivi alors
on me dit vous n'avez aucune compétence
pour le climat mais je dis bon mais je
suis désolé mais pendant 37 an moi moi
moi moi moi je suivais des marqueurs
sismiques qui étaient les changements
climatiqu alors j'en connais autant que
vous sur le climat hein bon tandis que
surtout qu'en plus de ça hein t tous les
tous les gars qui vous disent qui font
qui font
des simulations
du du CO2. Moi, la seule référence que
j'ai trouvé pour quelle est
la la
l'impact du CO2 dans les gaz à effet de
serre, c'est hein une situation, c'est
26 %, la vapeur d'eau, c'est 60. Et ça,
c'est partant clair. Moi, je cherche
encore qu'on me dise, hein, quelle est
la hein
l'influence du CO2 par nuage.
D'accord. Là là, je viens de recevoir un
graphique en ppm sur l'augmentation en
CO2 ou
ça a commencé vraiment à monter en
flèche à l'air industrielle quand même,
non ?
Et oui, mais mais il y a il y a des il y
a il y a
c'est quand même une sacré cross de OK.
Non,
non, non, parce que parce que Non, parce
que je suis désolé, je suis désolé.
Personne
n'a des mesures si s'il y a des mesures
qui quand même. Non,
non, non, mais non, attends, attends,
attendez, je j'attends simplement. À
l'heure actuelle, vous avez eu des
mesures qui ont été faites euh du CO2
par des scientifiques qui étaient fait
mesuré du CO2 et cetera, mais ça a été
hein Berk a fait des papiers, il y a il
y a des mesures qui ont été mesurées de
400 ppm il y a il y a 200 ans, mais on
dit non, c'est des artefacts, ils se
sont gourrés et cetera et on ne veut
considérer que les mesures qui ont été
faites dans les carottes de glace, hein,
la spécialité de Jouselle et cetera et
de l'orius.
Bon, or les dans les glaces euh alors
les les toutes les carottes de glace du
du grosland pour le CO2 sont considérées
comme mauvaises parce que c'est très
très pollué. Par exemple, la fin de
l'Empire romain, ça a été fait par les
ils ne trouvait plus de leur monnaie
d'argent dans les mines de Riotinto. Les
mines de Riotto ont été épuisées par les
Romains. Vous retrouvez, ils ont brûlé
tous les ar vous retrouvez ces ces ces
cres des Romains de Ryotinto dans les
glaces du Grandland. Donc le CO2 est
trop pollué. Donc il faut aller en
Antarctique pour avoir des mesures de
CO2 qui sont acceptables.
Or si vous avez vous allez à vos stocks,
les mesures ils ont mesuré jusqu'à hein
400000 ans puis maintenant ils sont
remontés un peu plus haut. Donc vous
avez ces
ces ces bulles de glace qui d'air
qui ont été des bulles d'air qui ne sont
qui sont dans la neige et qui ne sont
scellés qu'à 100 m de profondeur.
Or à vos stock, il tombe 5 cm hein.
C'est plus aride que le Sara
l'Antarctique, il ne tombe que 5 cm par
an. Donc pour arriver à voir le
sellement de ces bulles de gaz à vos
stock, il faut attendre 5000 ans. Donc
quand ils disent qu'il mesure le CO2
dans la glace, il mesure quelque chose
pendant ces 500 5000 ans. Les bulles ont
été en communication avec l'atmosphère.
Donc il mesurent quelque chose qui sont
lissés. Donc quand les gars qui vous
disent on mesure les mesures du du CO2,
si vous regardez sur les 5000 ans à
l'heure actuelle, hein, l'âge l'âge de
du pic pétrolier, ça va faire une pointe
qui va démarrer de 1850 et qui va
s'atteindre en 2050, 200 ans ou mettons
2100 et que là-dessus si vous vous
faites un lissage sur Saint-Milan, votre
pic pétrolier, il va complètement
devenir quelquement complètement aplati.
Donc les mesures de CO2 qui sont qui
viennent des carottes de glace qui sont
cité par tout le monde et cetera, elles
sont lissées et ça ils n'en tiennent pas
compte.
Et et euh vous avez discuté avec le GC
de tout ça, il pense quoi de de votre
Ben quand la seule fois que j'ai discuté
avec Jousell et cetera, mais enfin moi
je je suis je suis ouvert hein, mais bon
mais bon, ils ont leur idée et cetera et
puis bon mais je vous dis la seule fois
que j'ai discuté avec Jousell, il a plus
parlé, il a transformé, il a changé donc
les scénarios énergétiques dans du
forçage radiatif hein. Donc maintenant
c'est du W par mètre carré. Alors
maintenant, on peut plus on peut plus
rien dire par mètre carré. Moi, je suis
pas compétent
mais personne ne vous ne sait parce que
ils font des différences de de radiation
si vous voulez où les
mesures qu' font qui sont qui prennent
en considération l'effet de l'homme et
cetera sont inférieurs à la précision
des des mesures.
Ça ça vous intéresserait qu'on qu'on
vous fasse interagir avec Jean-Josel ?
Oh ben oui, moi j'ai dit oui oui
Nicolas Millant.
Moi je veux bien.
Moi j'ai euh si vous voulez il y a trois
problèmes dont on a parlé aujourd'hui.
Il y a il y a le pic pétrolier, on parle
du climat et on parle de la pollution.
Tous ces problèmes euh auront des
impacts importants. Le pétrolier, on en
a parlé,
le changement climatique, il est il est
incontestable. Là, ce dont discute Jean,
c'est quelle est la cause. Mais le fait
qu'il arrive, il est incontestable. Son
impact, il est incontestable. On l'a vu
aussi notamment dans des régions comme
en Syrie où il a été extrêmement fort.
Et l'impact de la pollution, il est
aussi incontestable, c'est 67000 morts
par an. La bonne nouvelle, c'est que ces
trois problèmes, ils ont la même
solution puisqu'ils ont les mêmes
origines, pétrole, charbon. Donc, la
priorité, c'est de se débarrasser au
plus vite du pétrole et de se
débarrasser au plus vite du charbon. Le
charbon 40 % de l'électricité 40 % de
l'électricité au niveau mondial 60 % de
la hausse des émissions de CO2 depuis
2000. Bon ben là c'est facile le
charbon. On s'en débarrasse comment ? En
réduisant sa part dans la production
d'électricité.
Au niveau du mix énergétique qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire
au niveau du mix énergétique
? On intensifie le nucléaire. On
intensifie les les
alors non, la première chose qu'on doit
faire déjà, je le dis souvent, on vous
parle souvent de transition énergétique.
Transition énergétique, c'est la plus
grande fake news qui existe. Ça n'existe
nulle part la transition. Le seul truc
que nous savons faire, ça s'appelle
l'empilement énergétique. On rajoute en
plus, on met des des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires en plus, du charbon,
du gaz. On met des voitures électriques
en plus, des voitures diesel. Mais pour
arriver à une transition énergétique, on
a besoin de passer par une case la plus
importante qui s'appelle la sobriété
énergétique. Puisque toutes ces énergies
qu'on veut remplacer, elles sont moins
denses que celles qu'elles remplacent.
Que ce soit la voiture électrique, vous
avez 100 fois moins d'énergie hein dans
1 kg de batterie que dans 1 kg de
pétrole. Que ce soit les panneaux
solaires, là c'est la densité
surfassique. Il vous faut beaucoup
beaucoup de place pour récupérer autant
d'énergie. Et donc si on veut
transitionner alors énergie un monde 100
% renouvelable ça ça existe. Ça
s'appelle le Moyen-âge hein que le vent
que le soleil et que l'eau. Ça
fonctionne mais on consomme moins avec
esclave.
Et donc il faut réduire ses besoins. La
première sage c'est de réduire ses
besoins. Moi mon domaine de prédilection
c'est le transport. Comment est-ce qu'on
réduit son besoin dans le transport ? Il
y a plusieurs façons de le faire. d'une
façon facile, on réduit sa vitesse,
c'est pas très populaire mais réduire sa
vitesse, ça permet de diminuer
significativement la consommation. Une
autre façon, on roule peut-être pas tous
dans des voitures qui font 1 tonne 4, 1
tonne 5 de tonnes, on réduit le poids
des voitures.
Une autre façon de réduire ça, au lieu
d'être tout seul dans sa voiture comme
90 % des gens qui vont au travail, on
monte à deux ou trois. Donc avant de
passer tous à la voiture électrique, on
réduit la taille de la voiture, elle
roule un peu moins vite, on monte à de
dedans et alors à ce moment-là, on va
pouvoir commencer à utiliser ses
synergies sans retomber sur d'autres
contraintes parce que la voiture
électrique, alors d'accord, elle utilise
pas de pétrole mais utilise des métaux,
on a parlé de lithium mais surtout
cobalt. Cobalt euh qu'on extrait en
grande majorité au Congo, qu'on raffine
à 80 % en Chine, sur lequel on a aucune
aucune indépendance. Je reviens à ce que
je voulais dire. Donc il faut d'abord
pour pas faire de l'empilement
énergétique mais de la transition, on
fait d'abord la sobriété. Une fois qu'on
a réduit nos besoins 30 % 40 % 50 % là
on peut commencer à faire différemment.
Comment on fait pour faire passer ça à
la population ? On fait une loi, on
interdit les vols intérieurs,
on oblige comme à Cuba à faire de
l'autostoop avec quatre personnes si
vous faites pas de
Alors, il y a des choses non, il y a des
choses aujourd'hui, il y a des choses
qui sont mises en place pour faire du
couvoiturage. C'est plus facile
qu'avant. Euh
sauf que ça crée ça crée un effet de
ça dépend quel covoiturage. Si vous
parlez du covoiturage longue distance
pour partir pour partir en vacance
effectivement là vous allez avoir ce
qu'on appelle un effet rebond.
C'est-àdire que j'étais chez moi dans
mon canapé, j'avais 10 € avec mes 10 €
je pouvais pas m'acheter un billet de
train. Par contre avec mes 10 € je peux
m'acheter un billet de voiture et donc
je vais rentrer dans cette voiture là et
je et je vais avoir un effet rebond.
Donc le gain du covoiturage longue
distance, on va dire qu'il est limité
s'il existe. Mais le vrai gain, c'est
sur le covoiturage court distance,
c'estàd que quand vous allez tous les
jours au travail parce que là vous êtes
sur un trajet contraint. Donc si vous
faites du covoiturage, vous allez pas
aller plus au travail, vous allez aller
toujours au travail. Euh et donc là, on
peut avoir des économies significatives.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez des systèmes, des
applications qui vous permettent de
faciliter la mise en relation dans les
entreprises pour que les gens puissent
coaturer. Donc ça ça existe. Bon, la
vitesse pas compliquée. Euh, il suffit
de la il suffit de la baisser. C'est ce
qu'on a fait lors des chocs pétroliers,
hein. Les limites de vitesse, ça datent
des chocs pétroliers. Et puis la
troisième solution, c'est quelque chose
que je vais proposer dans une note qui
va être publiée demain par France
Stratégie. Comment est-ce qu'on réduit
le le poids des voitures ? Et bien, on
peut mettre par exemple une fiscalité
sur un élément alors pas de fiscalité
plutôt de bonus malus qui fait que si tu
achètes une voiture qui pèse le poids
moyen ton 3, une tonne 4, ça te coûte
rien. Si tu achètes une voiture qui est
plus légère alors on va te donner un peu
d'argent et si tu achètes une voiture
qui est beaucoup plus lourde alors ça va
te coûter plus cher. Et donc ça c'est
une façon de réorienter les voitures
vers des voitures plus légères qui
consomment moins de pétrole et qui vont
consommer moins de batteries et cetera
quand on va les électrifier. Donc les
solutions existent maintenant il suffit
de les mettre en place.
Je voudrais je voudrais qu'on parle de
démographique corrélée à la consommation
énergétique. Est-ce que ça existe des
études sur la démographie en fonction de
la consommation énergétique ?
Non mais moi je sais que j'ai fait j'ai
fait pas mal le fait pas mal de
prévisions et notamment les courbes de
Uber et cetera. Donc et euh j'ai
appliqué la même méthode pour prévoir la
production de pétrole que pour la
population hein. D'ailleurs,
ça a été fait dans les années 80 par un
gars de Linette qui s'appelait comment ?
me souviens plus euh qui qui faisait des
des cycles de Uber sur sur la
population. Donc euh moi je si vous
voulez dans les années 2000, je disais
attention, il y a un pic pétrolier mais
il y a pas de problème parce que quand
je regarde mes mes croissances de la
population,
je vois hein que je vais avoir un pic de
la population vers 2050. Donc je disais
il y a pas de problème, la population
va baisser en même temps que le pétrole
et l'énergie. Donc je disais il y a pas
il y a pas trop de problème. On va s'y
passer. Mais ça ça se passait dans les
années 90
et depuis 2000 si vous voulez
la la croissance qui était montée à 80
millions à peu près était descendu à 70.
Maintenant, c'est remonté parce que
vous parlez en baril par jour là.
Non non, je parle d'un million de de de
millions de populations.
D'accord.
Bon euh et si vous voulez toutes les
prévisions qui étaient faites sur la
population étaient fait par les Nations-
Unies sur des taux de fécondité. Donc
j'ai fait pas mal de papiers sur les
taux de fécondité et cetera. Or euh les
Nations- Unies, sans leurs prévisions,
c'est des prévisions utopiques. Donc ils
ont dit euh toute euh la taux de
fécondité sont différents mais tout le
monde va aller vers le m But qui est en
2300, ça c'était dans les années 2000,
on sera tous à 2,1 qui est le taux de
remplacement. Donc voyez, la population
sera stable. Donc pour arriver à voir
des des fécondités comme par exemple les
américaines
qui était bien inférieur aux Mexicaines,
il il disait ça va remonter et donc les
prévisions qui étaient fait en l'an 2000
étaient fait qu'en en l'an 2020 la
fécondité des l'américaine serait
supérieure à la fécondité des
mexicaines. Al moi je l'ai donné
actuelle, c'est faux hein. Mais tout ça
c'était l'utopie de dire et cetera et
que toutes les prévisions qui étaient
faites en Afrique étaient de fait parce
que le le Nigéria si si vous voulez la
la population en France était à se
enfants par femme en 1700 et on a
la mortalité était importante. Oui. Oui,
c'est ça. C'est la mortalité parce que
le le problème c'est que toute la
transition démographique qui a été
imaginée était le fait que autrefois on
avait une mortalité élevée et une
natalité élevée et que les pays
développés ont fait baisser les deux à
la fois.
Or en Afrique ce que ce que l'on a fait
c'est tous les ONG ont été leur apporté
la médecine pour diminuer la mortalité
mais ils n'ont rien fait pour la
natalité. Ils ne leur pas apporté la
pilule parce que
Ah non, on leur a apporté les guerres,
c'est plus efficace.
Oui. Oui. Non mais enfin parce que
l'heure actuelle, moi je reprends les
prévisions de l'an 2000 des Nations-
Unies sur le Nigéria.
À l'heure actuelle, il devrait être à
trois enfants par femme. Ils sont
toujours à cinq.
le si vous regardez les variations du
Nigéria parce que le Nigéria à l'heure
actuelle hein sur les prévisions
actuelles va dépasser en 2050 va
dépasser l'Europe
ils seront à 700 milliards 700 millions
alors que la l'Europe sera à moins de
700 puisquil on décroit
et que le le problème c'est que on leur
a tout fait pour le apporter pour
diminuer la mortalité mais rien pour la
natalité parce qu'il fallait surtout pas
intervenir parce qu'en plus de ça la
natalité dans ces pays-là c'est c'est
l'assurance vieillesse hein. C'est pour
c'est pour ramasser le bois, aller
chercher l'eau et et pour se s'occuper
des des anciens.
Nicolas Mayant ?
Non, je pense qu'il y a un lien très
fort entre la démographie et l'énergie.
Effectivement, avant quand on avait des
enfants, le but c'était d'avoir des
bras, de pouvoir aller aller dans les
champs. Plus les pays sont riche, plus
les pays ont un un Payb par tête élevé,
plus souvent aussi ils vont être éduqués
et là plus on a des natalités faibles.
Il faut rappeler que le le problème que
l'on a, c'est entre guillemets un
problème de riche. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui
c'est c'est 10 % de la population
mondiale dans lequel se trouvent tous
les Français qui crée à 50 % plus de la
moitié des problèmes. Donc et c'est on
dit souvent quand les quand les gens se
disent oui mais regarde le problème
c'est que là-bas dans ces pays font 5 6
7 enfants. C'est triste à dire mais ces
5 6 7 enfants ils consomment rien. Donc
leur impact sur la planète il est nul.
un enfant en France va consommer
l'équivalent peut-être de 5 enfants en
Inde et peut-être d'une dizaine au
Nigéria. Donc le vrai problème de
natalité, il est aussi à régler dans les
pays riches et ça c'est bah un sujet qui
est très compliqué à gérer. Mais le
problème de la surconsommation c'est pas
un problème de pauvres, c'est vraiment
un problème de riche et ça c'est
vraiment un débat qui est qui est acté.
Donc au lieu qu'on monte les les ça va
poser d'autres problèmes he la natalité
en Afrique puisque comme on a fait
sauter la Libye le bouchon ils vont
quand même avoir envie une partie
d'entre eux de de venir chez nous mais
c'est surtout un problème qu'on doit
régler chez nous et c'est les pays
riches les plus riches qui doivent
vraiment changer de comportement. On
parle de sobriété c'est vraiment à nous
de à nous de réduire notre niveau de
consommation parce que sinon de toute
façon tous ces gens-là ils veulent avoir
le même que le nôtre. Donc on doit se
rejoindre quelque part mais quelque part
qui est beaucoup plus bas. Alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut
conserver si vous voulez, on parle
toujours du PIB mais on peut conserver
un niveau de vie de service équivalent à
aujourd'hui avec un PIB beaucoup plus
faible. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il suffit de
se passer les choses. Il suffit de les
de pas posséder chacun sa voiture qu'on
utilise 5 % du temps, chacun sa perceuse
qu'on utilise un jour par an et cetera.
Il suffit d'avoir une perceuse pour tout
l'immeuble. Il suffit d'avoir et donc on
est capable aujourd'hui sans sans faire
baisser le service d'avoir une une
société qui consomme beaucoup moins. Par
contre, c'est plus le même modèle
économique. C'est plus le modèle
économique où on produit à plus savoir
qu'en faire et que surtout au bout de ou
3 ans, il faut que ça parte à la
poubelle pour qu'on reproduise un
Oui.
On a on arrive bientôt à la fin de de
notre interview. Est-ce que vous voyez
des sujets qu'on a pas abordé ou vous
voulez aborder ?
Ah oui bah peut-être le pic pétrolier.
J'avais juste juste un truc à dire sur
sur le pic pétrolier. Euh en fait depuis
2005, entre 2005 et aujourd'hui, vous
avez deux pays. Vous avez en gros tous
les pays du monde qui sont compensés,
ceux qu'on monté, ceux qu'on baissé.
Vous avez deux pays qui font qu'on a
augmenté, qui font la la différence de
la hausse. L'Irak,
alors il se trouve qu'on a pas trouvé
d'armes de destruction massive, mais ils
ont trouvé du pétrole. Donc, on a
multiplié la production par de
On les avait trouvé parce que c'est
chiant. il a long temps qu'ils ont été
ou donc par 2 et demi et l'autre pays
c'est les États-Unis donc en fait le pic
pétrolier il repose sur ces deux pays
comment va évoluer la production de
pétrole en Irak
et comment va évoluer la production de
pétrole aux États-Unis et est-ce que
l'histoire du pétrole de Chisse aux
États-Unis est-ce qu'on est capable de
la reproduire ailleurs ? Est-ce qu'on
peut la reproduire en Chine ? Est-ce
qu'on peut la reproduire en Russie ?
Est-ce qu'on peut la reproduire en
Argentine ? Donc le pic pétrolier moi je
dis souvent surveiller ces deux pays-là.
Alors l'Irak à mon avis je suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse encore beaucoup augmenter
la production mais effectivement aux
États-Unis euh je vous parlais des
opérateurs, 90 % des opérateurs qui ne
gagnent pas d'argent, un un un milieu
qui a été euh qui a été
subventionné enfin qui où on avait de
l'argent gratuit hein avec les
politiques centrales. le jour où on a
une crise économique et financière, il
va falloir regarder ce qui se passe sur
ce secteur là et notamment le bassin du
permis.
Et là, on sera pas très très loin
à mon avis d'un pic d'un pic pétrolier
et là d'une longue descente longue
descente énergétique.
Bon, moi je voulais simplement vous
dire, je suis un peu effrayé parce que
là je ne verrai pas, c'est que les
prévisions officielles en 2040 hein, que
vous dire ça sera que l'Europe, vous
voyez c'est les prévisions d'Exon mais
celle de la que en pas hésitez pas à
montrer à la voà. qu'en 2040, vous
voyez, vous avez l'Amérique ici qui va
exporter. Voyez, en 2040, c'est ça.
Oui.
Et vous avez l'Europe qui a besoin de
ça,
hein. Voyez ? Bon. Et donc, hein, tout
le monde dit hein, il va y avoir ça va
devenir le l'Europe qui a hein, ça c'est
sa demande et ça c'est sa production.
Donc ça va venir d'où ? Ça va venir
d'Amérique du Nord et ça va venir du
Moyen-Orient.
Mais ça c'est basé sur le pétrole
d'idochiste et
les prévisions. Si vous regardez
maintenant mes prévisions de
d'importation aux États-Unis, voyez au
aux États-Unis, on a toujours importé
enfin en Amérique du Nord, on a importé
de l'énergie. Donc vous voyez
ça ça on démarre en euh
de 1970. Voilà 70 on monte avec le pic
pétrolier. Donc il il consomme moins,
donc il diminue pétrolier
hein, ça baisse et puis ça reprend et
puis euh hein ça baisse là voyez avec ça
c'est le pétrole de chiste. Donc eux ils
disent ça va continuer par là et moi je
dis ça va remonter parce que ça va
s'arrê les vont importer.
Donc moi je dis ils vont reorter comme
ils importaient ici et non pas exporter.
Donc on a la même chose pour le gaz,
c'est exactement la même chose. Et que
par exemple quand vous avez Trump qui va
engueuler Merkel sur le N stream 2 en
disant il faut s'époler à Poutine parce
que qu'est-ce que veut faire Trump ? Il
veut vendre du gaz liquéfié en 2040 qui
vient du gaz de Chiste. Mais il y en
aura pas d'après mes prévisions. Alors
je peux avoir tort mais je dis mes
prévisions, elles sont aussi bonnes et
je les justifie beaucoup plus que leurs
prévisions à eux. Or hein tout le monde
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
c'est sûr on aura le gaz de chiste
américain en 2040. Moi je dis je suis
pas sûr du tout et vous ne
ce sera quand même le N stream avec
Poutine.
Ben il faudra il faudra en 2040 il y
aura pas le gaz de chiste américain mais
il y aura toujours le gaz russe.
On arrive on arrive donc à à à la fin de
notre notre interview. Je vais vous
poser deux trois petites questions qu'on
a pas pu passer de de la communauté.
Euh comment résoudre le problème de
transmission de l'information aux
générations futures ? Grand problème.
Grand problème parce que à l'heure
actuelle
le le le le le fake news abonde
abondamment et vous ne pouvez plus faire
le tri et que et que je dis les les les
sociétés enfin les organismes comme
l'insed et cetera qui devraient faire le
le boulot le font pas. Ils le font mal
ou ils le font mal, ils le font mal,
hein. Moi, je suis pour il faut avoir
des longues séries
euh historique pour expliquer le le
futur avec le passé, mais il faut avoir
des données fiables et cetera. Et et en
France, vous ne les avez pas. Je vais
vous dire un exemple hein. Depuis que
l'énergie est passée à l'écologie,
autrefois euh il y avait ce qu'on
appelait le bureau d'exploration et de
de production des hydrocarbures
euh
donner toutes les productions
des champs français.
Depuis que ce ce ce ce truc là a été
rattaché à l'écologie, ça a été
supprimé. Maintenant Maintenant euh le
niveau euh
qui s'en occupe, c'est je ne sais plus
comment il s'appelle, le B je crois, ils
ont en en 2050, ils ont dit on ne publie
plus les productions euh des champs
français alors que l'on avait dans le
futur, moi je dis, je suis désolé, c'est
contre le
je dirais le droit de l'homme de 1789.
Euh moi je paye euh les fonctionnaires
pour qu'ils me donnent des informations
et non pas pour qu'ils veuillent mettre
l'omerta sur euh la production des
champ.
On on en est où avec les scandales des
torchères euh en Afrique ?
Bon, les torch les torchères aller aller
voir aller voir les les à l'heure
actuelle vous avez euh j'ai fait des
très beau graphique qui qui est le prix
du gaz par rapport au prix de l'huile
aux États-Unis en fonction de du
torchage. Alors le
torchez par exemple dans le bacon dans
le bacon rappeler à notre communauté ce
que c'est le torchage. le torchage.
C'est-à-dire que quand vous avez ce qui
se passe à l'heure actuelle sur les gaz
de ce qu'on appelle l'TO light tiil du
bacon en nors d'Aota,
le prix du gaz est très faible. Vous le
construire des gaz aucement.
Ça vaut transporter le gaz coûte 10 fois
plus de cher que le pétrole. Je juste
faut rappeler que le gaz sur au bacon
c'est en fait du gaz qui est associé à
la production de pétrole.
Donc on produit le pétrole et on a du
gaz avec et on sait pas quoi en faire.
Donc donc qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ils le
torchent. Donc vous avez par exemple le
gaz en or d'Aota, vous avez 35 % du gaz
qui était torché. Alors ils ont fait des
interdictions mais enfin ça ça continue.
Donc si vous voulez il est gaspillé.
Mais pourquoi ? Parce que le prix du gaz
alors aux États-Unis est trois fois
moins cher que le prix du pétrole. Et et
en Afrique, quand quand ça ça torche un
fond, que les particules retombent sur
les villages, tout va bien. Non, c'est
ça.
Non, mais le torchage le torchage, vous
avez euh la plupart du temps de torchage
qui était dans les usines raffineries,
vous avez une torche, c'est la sécurité
parce qu'il faut que si jamais il y a
une surpression,
que ça ne soit pas du le gaz ne se
répand pas dans l'atmosphère sans être
brûlé parce qu' il exploserait. Donc
vous avez une torchère, les torchères
que vous voyez dans les raffineries,
c'est la plupart de la sécurité.
Et mais l'idée l'idée c'est c'est de de
torcher un minimum si le prix du gaz est
intéressant. Mais les pétroliers c'est
aussi le coût écologique est taxé
tellement fort que ça oblige à
responsabiliser les pétroliers. Non mais
mais oui mais enfin le torchage je suis
désolé c'est aussi c'est un gaspillage
mais il est exactement
ça pollue aux alentours quand même hein.
Ça pollue ça pollue. Le le l'agriculture
a été basée sur les feux de forêt. Les
agriculteurs ont toujours brûlé de la
forêt pour pour faire descendre et pour
c'était bon ils ont toujours brûlé et ça
se fait fait encore de toute façon.
Vous êtes en train de comparer les feux
de forêt du torchage là ? Ah ben oui oui
oui. Non mais c'est donc si vous voulez
le le torch le le le le le torch les les
feux les feux le euh le l'homme de de
Cromagnon et il il faisait ses ses il
brûlait il brûlait des feux pour faire
cuire sa viande. Bon maintenant on a le
micro-ondes mais bon
on continue de se taper dessus à coup de
bâton. Oui oui. Non mais
Nicolas Nicolas dites-moi Jean. Non mais
je je dis le le torchage c'est parce que
les prix du gaz sont trop faibles. Il
n'y a aucun profit
ou que l'amand écologique est pas assez
et pas assez exactement. Non mais ça
devrait être ça c'est la faiblesse la
faiblesse des Américains. Bon
ou la faiblesse des africains pour
imposer au pétroli de d'
Non non je suis désolé le en Angola le
le gars appartient au aux Angolais.
Ouais ouais
il appartient pas au pétroliers hein.
Il y a pas de piraterie en Angola
comme un peu dans dans le D3 du Niger.
Non. Ah non, ben parce que ils ont moins
de ils ont moins de différentes
communautés ethniques. Le Nigéria, c'est
c'est c'est ça ça.
Nicolant Nicolas Mayant, est-ce que vous
pouvez il y a une question d'Internet,
pouvez-vous nous parler du rapport
Midose en quelques mots ?
Alors le rapport Midose en quelques
mots, moi c'est c'est ça qui m'a fait
m'intéresser au sujet. Donc j'étais
sensible aux thématiques de l'énergie de
l'environnement et c'est et c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'a fait un
déclic. Donc Mido, c'est un rapport
c'est des chercheurs étudiants
chercheurs OMIT qui est sur une
commande.
Vous avez fait l'OMIT vous nous aussi ?
Non,
exactement mais 30 années plus tard et
qui et qui sur une commande du club de
Rome ont construit un modèle systémique.
C'estàd que c'est le premier modèle
économique qui en gros prend en compte
que la Terre est ronde. D'accord ? qu'il
y a des stocks dans lequels on va on va
on va aller taper et en gros ils ont
modélisé en prenant le production
industrielle,
la santé, la population, la pollution,
l'énergie euh et quelques autres
facteurs que j'ai oublié euh pour voir
un petit peu comment ça pouvait tourner
cette histoire-là à horizon 50 100 ans.
et ils ont fait des scénarios à énergie
limitée, ils ont fait des scénarios
pollution illimitée, ils ont fait
beaucoup de scénarios et ils en sont
arrivés à un constat, c'est que sans
donner de précision sur la date,
à horizon, on va dire mi-20e siècle, ça
allait coincer.
On savait, ils savent pas quelle donnée
allait coincer en premier, mais ça
allait créer ensuite euh pas un
effondrement, mais au moins une lente,
une lente descente.
Et donc et donc ça c'est ce qu'ils ont
et ça n'a jamais été ça n'a jamais été
égalé. Et en fait, vous avez eu un
rapport
30 ans plus tard qui a été fait, même 40
ans plus tard pour corréler un peu ce
qu'ils avaient dit et ce qui s'est
passé. Et on se rend compte que là on
est quand même sur un scénario qui est
assez fidèle à ce qu'il disait qu'ils
étaient appelés le business à jou et
donc il voit dans les pour pas dire de
entre aujourd'hui et peut-être 2050
qu'on aura passé notre pic tout sachant
que une des données d'entrée importantes
du rapport MIDOS c'est aussi la
disponibilité des ressources et Denis
Midas passe souvent parle souvent
d'ailleurs de pétroliers
il y a gens qui lèvent le doigt
ou petit rectificatif c'est c'est un
rapport qui s'appelle un limite tout
grosse de du club de Rome. limite de la
croissance.
Ouais. Voilà. Et qui a été dirigé par
Dona Médose
? Oui. qui était qui était qui était
marié à Denis Mose qui était qui était
l'informaticien de service,
hein. Sa femme, il a divorcé et sa femme
est morte et lui, il est le survivant
qui s'attribue, je dirais les mérites de
ce de ce ce rapport alors que c'était sa
femme qui était l'élément,
c'était le chef de projet et cetera.
Rendon à César ce qui est à César
comment s'appuse donner la midose mais
étaient toute une équipe
donuse et son nom son nom de jeune fille
c'était
Ah je pourrais pas te j'ai pas cette
information là
mais en tout cas c'est c'est un rapport
qui est vraiment fondamental euh parce
que c'est le vous savez le quand on
regarde les
les gens qui font de l'économie ils vous
disent bah la croissance 2060 2 % par an
on tire la droite ça s'appelle une
fonction exponentielle
et ça la seule chose dont on est sûr
c'est que ça n'arrivera pas. Donc en
gros le je vous dis le modèle Mido c'est
et ça n'a pas été reproduit depuis club
de
alors le rapport du club de robe limite
tout grosse c'est le seul le seul le
seul modèle qui prend en compte que il
était c il était pas que les deux hein
le couple il était il était cinq he
il y avait je Forester qui c le
professeur et il y en a deux trois
autres j'ai oublié le nom
question d'internet comment
expliquez-vous la persistance de nos
politiques à vouloir faire du green
washing avec de l'énergie verte non
pilotable dans dans un pays qui a autant
investi dans le nucléaire.
Oui, mais là encore il y a une
écroquerie en disant que les en disant
que certains produisent de l'énergie
verte. Le l'électron nucléaire n'est pas
distinguible distingable de l'électron
éolien hein. Et que il rachète tous ces
tous ces vendeurs d'énergie verte, ils
achètent ça la plupart à
ils revendent, ils rachètent, ils ont
par la loi si vous voulez. Moi, je suis
je ne suis pas du tout contre l'éolien.
Ce par contre, je suis contre payer une
taxe qui s'appelle la CSPE, hein, la
contribution solidaire de production
d'électricité qui est de 22 centimes par
kil kWh
qui qui permet de subventionner l'éolien
alors qu'on me prétend qu'il est
économique et qui coûte moins cher que
le Alors moi je veux bien de l'éolien
mais je veux hein d'abord il a un
privilège
exorbitant, c'est que le renouvelable
éolien et solaire est prioritaire au
nucléaires.
Et donc quand ils produisent, hop, on
arrête le nucléaire. Mais par contre
quand il n'y a pas parce que hein,
l'éolien c'est 23 % du temps en France
et le solaire 11 %. Le reste du temps
c'est intermittent et il faut hein autre
chose. Alors c'est pas les barrages qui
suffisent, il faut du nucléaire. Alors,
les gens qui rêvent de supprimer le
nucléaire, je je vais je me demande
comment ils feront quand ils ils verront
qu'ils n'ont pas d'électricité quand
quand il y a pas de soleil. Donc moi, je
veux bien des hein des éoliens mais je
ne vois pas pourquoi je les subventionne
qui puisqu'ils ont déjà l'avantage
d'être prioritaire sur le nucléaire.
Je vais faire une petite petite analyse
rétrospective. Euh, on va se plonger en
j'ai une interprétation différente. Je
pense que c'est surtout politique. On se
plonge en 1998.
Euh Guérard Schoder obtient la majorité
en Allemagne. Il lui manque 6 millions
de voix, 3 % des 3 % des votes. Euh non,
c'est de l'inverse d'ailleurs. C'est
plutôt aussi 3 millions de voix, 6 % des
votes. Et là, il fait une alliance.
Donc, il a besoin de faire une alliance
avec les verts pour 6 % des voix. Et les
vert lui disent, tu vas être chancelier,
très bien, mais tu sors du nucléaire.
Donc en Allemagne, en 2000, on décide de
la sortie du nucléaire sur cet accord
électoral
pour continuer la la petite histoire du
nucléaire. Et donc c'est à ce moment-là
qui décide aussi de développer le
renouvelable et l'éolien et ça ne
plaisait pas du tout d'ailleurs aux gens
du CDU notamment Angela Merkel qui
pourtant est plutôt écologiste et
ministre de l'environnement à l'origine
en 2010. Peu de gens le savent mais
Angela Merkel dit écoutez je regarde nos
émissions de CO2, ça baisse pas assez
vite. Donc ce qu'on va faire c'est que
le nucléaire on va le garder 10 ans de
plus. Je sais pas 2020 mais 2030 et on
va sortir du charbon en premier pour
pouvoir réduire nos émissions de CO2. 6
mois plus tard, Fukushima écoutez,
finalement on va revenir au plan
d'origine et on va plutôt ressortir du
nucléaire et garder le charbon.
Donc en fait les verrs avec un accord
électoral ont réussi à sortir du avoir
cette sortie de nucléaire en Allemagne.
Donc ce sont les modèles les ver
allemands des verrs français.
Souvenez-vous 2012 souvenez-vous 2012
François Hollande se fait élire comment
? Il gagne avec les voies des écolos
parce qu'il a promis 50 % nucléaires. 50
% de quoi on sait pas. Le débat national
sur la transition énergétique se fait
pendant 4 5 ans pour valider la promesse
du candidat Hollande.
Le mot pétrole apparaît peut-être une
fois ou deux fois dans dans le projet de
loi alors que c'est les de tiers des
émissions de CO2 en France. Les 2/
tiers. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Emmanuel Macron devient président,
Nicolas ministre de l'environnement on
fait des scénarios énergétiques et on se
rend compte on va pas pouvoir sortir à
la fois du charbon et du nucléaire en
même temps. Donc fin de l'histoire, on
oublie la promesse de 50 % et on l'a des
cas, je sais plus 2030 ou 2035. On a un
vrai problème en Europe et là je veux je
veux quand même alerter, c'est que
l'Europe est née et s'est créée sur
l'énergie.
C'était la CA, la Communité européenne
du charbon et de l'acier. L'énergie,
c'est un un sujet profondément européen
et c'est encore plus sur l'électricité
parce que tout est interconnecté et
aujourd'hui tous les pays font leurs
petits plans dans leur coin. Ah ben moi
je ferme le nucléaire, moi je ferme le
charbon, moi je ferme le gaz. Sauf que
dans 2 3 ans, tout le monde aura fermé
ses trucs. On sera tous avec nos
panneaux solésoliennes.
Mais le jour où il y aura plus de pas de
vent et pas de soleil,
on va être tous en noir.
On fera pédaler les vieux. Ça va pas se
passer comme ça parce que quand vous
êtes tous en noir changera, c'est quand
on aura un black
quand sera dans le noir.
Ce blackout il arrive à horizon alors
2025, je vais être optimiste.
On en parle des blackout de plus en
plus. Le blackout, il va arriver parce
que là tous les pays quand la France
fait sa politique énergétique, elle ne
parle pas à l'Allemagne. Quand
l'Allemagne fait sa politique
énergétique, elle ne parle pas aux
autres pays. Il y a deux pays qui font
les besoins de base en Europe, c'est
France Allemagne, hein. Ça va être
quelque chose comme entre peut-être 150
150 Go donc on a besoin de ressources de
base et on doit s'organiser et
aujourd'hui tout le monde fait les
choses dans son coin et ça va nous
emmener au chaos au chaos énergétique.
Et qui dit chaos énergétique dit
récession, dit troupes sociaux, dit des
choses comme ça. Quand vous coupez
l'électricité en blackout, euh il y a
beaucoup de choses qui commencent à
aller mal assez vite. Vous avez pas trop
intérêt à ce que ça dure trop longtemps.
Ouais. dis-moi politique. C'est la seule
façon don les gens changeront de d'idée
sur la façon de consommer hein. C'est
quand il
s
il faut il faut attendre un événement
exotique fédérator pour que les gens
parce que les gens c'est le seul moment
c'est le seul moment où les gens vont
dire attendez j'ai loupé un truc. Bah
oui, tu as loupé un truc effectivement.
Et donc on va refaire le chemin à
l'envers et puis on
en fait il fallait il fallait dire ça au
début de l'interview hein.
Je
trop tard pour en parler mais c'est
vraiment non c'est un sujet très très
important et l'Europe euh ne travaille
pas sur ces sujets. C'est très
surprenant.
Personne
la politique aujourd'hui de l'Europe
juste je reparle quand même de cette
négociation de Jean-Coul Junker qui m'a
quand même surpris. Je te laisse après
parler aujourd'hui.
Tu laisses parler tout de suite. Tiens
Jean prend la parole. Oui oui. Non, moi
je vais le dire, vous avez on a eu un un
un prix Nobel hein euh de l'économie
hein bien communol.
Vous l'avez lu le bouquin
de gentirol ?
Oui.
C'est une fable ? C'est pas une fable ?
Non, c'est pas une fable. Le mot énergie
n'existe pas.
Après c'est un économiste.
Non, c'est un économiste. Je suis désolé
mais bon il va falloir
si si le mot énergie n'existe pas, c'est
une fable.
C'est pas une fable, c'est une vue un
peu un peu un peu bornée du du bien
commun.
Idéologique.
C'est pas idéologique, c'est que il est
de l'ancienne école.
Bon, on vous réinvitera. Tu veux
rajouter quelque chose ?
Oui. Non, je voulais dire parler un peu
de la politique énergétique européenne
parce que la bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'on
part de très loin qu' a priori on peut
que aller mieux. On part d'une
négociation qui a eu lieu, c'était le
jour de gloire, je pense, pour
Jean-Claude Junker qui était à la Maison
Blanche euh avec Donald Trump où sous
les menaces de tarifs sur les
importations de voitures européennes,
principalement allemande, euh ils ont
réussi une superbe négociation qui
consiste à dire "Tu ne taxes pas mes
tanks mes tanks mes tanks allemands et
en échange, je te rachète ton euh ton
soja OGM et ton gaz de chiste.
Et euh et si vous allez voir sur le site
de la Commission européenne, vous voyez
que régulièrement la Commission
européenne se vente d'augmenter ces
importations de gaz de chiste des
États-Unis. Donc on en est là. Euh donc
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a de la
marge pour progresser, pour faire mieux
que ça. Euh mais malheureusement il y a
mais la route est assez longue. Euh il y
a une question qui est très intéressante
de la communauté là et on fait aucune
répétition en cas de blackout. Est-ce
que vous avez entendu parler de l'État
qui fait des simulations de blackout sur
les systèmes de santé ? Je sais qu'il y
a des grou
qui s'est produit. Ça s'est produit au
Québec mais c'était pas le problème de
l'homme, c'était la nature, c'était les
orages magnétiques qui va un de ses
jours arriver. On va avoir un blackout
magnétique qui vient qui vient de le de
l'au-delà de l'espace qui là là aussi on
va
sachant qu'on a aussi parlé récemment
on va parce qu'on est tout basé tout sur
l'informatique et cetera, mais quand
tout ça va s'éteindre hein tous ces ces
gens qui sont accrochés à à leur
smartphone je sais pas comment ils vont
faire hein. On a parlé récemment, j'ai
vu de surtout de d'attaque de réseau
électrique de hacking,
un papier qui parlait de l'Iran et qui
disait de toute façon si les États-Unis
disaient si les Iran nous emmerdent, on
coupe l'électricité. Donc on aura
peut-être aussi des attaques, des
blackouts.
Paraît-il paraît-il que l'Amérique du
Sud, c'était une un coup de semonce en
en terme de de
Je ne suis pas renseigné, mais ce qui ce
qui est sûr, c'est que maintenant tous
ces réseaux sont connectés. Donc si on
est capable de s'infiltrer, on est
capable de faire beaucoup de choses et
c'est des réseaux qui sont extrêmement
importants. Alors les hôpitaux,
heureusement, ils ont des tout les trucs
critiques, ils ont des ils ont des
batteries et des groupes et cetera, mais
ça dure un certain temps. Et donc on va
rentrer un peu dans un monde de
blackout.
Ouais.
Euh donc sur ces mots gentils, je vais
vous demander de laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations. Alors d'habitude
c'est Nicolas qui commence mais là on va
faire commencer Jean.
Ça va laisser le temps à Nicolas de
réfléchir sur ce conseil aux jeunes
génération. Ben moi aux jeunes
générations,
moi je je dis puisque j'ai été dans le
seul métier où on avait le droit de
tromper 9 fois sur 10, hein. Mais donc
c'était un grand avantage mais la
contrepartie c'est qu'il fallait tenir
compte de nos échecs et on apprend
beaucoup des échecs. Donc moi je je dis
un gars quand il a le grand reproche que
je dis c'est un gars il a jamais fait de
trop sec donc il a jamais appris il a
donc il ne faut pas avoir peur des
échecs d'ailleurs il faut prendre des
risques. Là où il y a pas de risque il y
a pas de profit donc il faut avoir le
sens du risque et le sens que les échecs
vous vous améliorent.
Il y a si vous voulez
en en français quand quand on ne connaît
pas la solution,
on dit en français on réseau ça par
approximation successive. Et moi j'aime
beaucoup le terme américain, c'est tra
un erreur. Voyez, c'est pas
l'approximation. Non, il faut tenir
compte de ces échecs. Il ne faut pas
avoir peur des échecs.
C'est une qualité.
C'est une qualité. Nicolas Mayant, un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Quand on parle de ces sujets-là, quand
on parle de d'écologie, quand on parle
de pic pétrolier, de climat, c'est
jamais une ambiance très fun quand on
est jeune. Pour se projeter, c'est pas
forcément évident.
Moi, je ce que je conseilleraiis aux
jeunes génération, c'est d'être
optimiste.
J'aime bien la façon que Philippe Biwix
a de parler de ce problème là. Le monde
va être différent.
Peut-être qu'on consommera moins
d'antidépresseurs qu'on en consomme
aujourd'hui. On est un pic anti
peut-être que le pic pétrolier sera
aussi un pic antidépresseur. Il faut que
les il faut que les jeunes, il faut
commencer à s'organiser. Il faut bien
évidemment rien attendre des autres. Il
faut vous organiser par rapport à ces
contraintes. Commencez à changer vos
comportements parce que comme ça vous en
souffrirez moins. Un pays qui va pas
souffrir par exemple c'est Cuba. Eux ils
ont une pétrolien en 90
et Madagascar
et Madagascar. Donc ces pays pauvres ils
vont pas s'en rendre compte. Il faut
commencer à s'organiser, à augmenter sa
résilience et puis surtout il faut quand
on veut et quand on a un peu d'énergie,
il faut contribuer. Il faut contribuer
et devenir vrai acteur de ce changement
là. Donc il peut y avoir des vocations
et à son petit niveau à son niveau
pouvoir contribuer à ce changement là
parce qu'on aura besoin de on aura
besoin de tout le monde.
Messieurs. Merci.
Merci à vous aussi.
[Musique]